This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is one of the podcasts that we
recorded.
Why we recording the Scifi show,
Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
A lot of people have listened
to those shows and they've said,
hey man,
I love your show,
but the fucking fig
podcasts are killing me.
They actually weren't fake.
The way we did the show was
we did everything that we
do during a normal podcast
and [inaudible] and then we just
talked about the subject at hand.
And of course a lot of times the
subjects went on crazy tangents like,
like any other podcasts that we do.
Uh,
but they were all recorded
just like a regular podcast.
And then we had the Scifi people or um,
the,
uh,
people at Arthur Smith,
the production company that made the show,
um,
edit down portions of it and insert those.
So there were some
things that we said that,
you know,
sort of busy work,
like w things that we had to say,
like,
Dunkin,
I'm going to send you to go check,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
There was just stuff that
we had to do for the show.
But other than that,
the majority of it was just regular
podcast talk and I promise you guys that I
would release it and uh,
thanks to the generosity of Scifi,
they have allowed us to do so.
So we're going to put all
these podcasts out there.
How many of them are there,
Jamie?
10 or 11.
So there's like 10 or 11.
They range between,
uh,
two hours plus for this first one to
short ones are probably like an hour
something,
something along those lines.
But uh,
this is the first one and this
one is brought to you by ting.
So if you go to rogan.ting.com you
can find out what Ting is all about.
Ting is an excellent cell phone service
company that uses the sprint backbone.
And Sprint of course is one of the biggest
cell phone providers in the world and
in the country.
So you don't have to worry about getting
a crappy cell phone signal along with
saving money.
But with Tim does is they have it set up
so that you only pay for what you use.
If you have,
like if you go to the,
if you go to rogan.ting.com there's a
sign that says 98% of people would save
money with Ting.
That's because we do mobile
differently and they really do.
It's not bullshit if you don't use,
if you like,
say if you have one plan and
then you use less than that plan,
they will credit you the
difference on your next bill.
Who the fuck does that?
Nobody,
nobody does that.
Tim does that.
$21 is the average monthly bill per
device per device for 10 customers.
That's fucking nuts.
$440 is the average annual savings per
device for a business with 11 to 20
employees.
I mean Ting is bad ass and
they have great phones.
They have the HTC one,
which is uh,
a one my friend at Google gave
me that I've been playing with.
I love it.
It's a great phone.
It's really cool.
The,
uh,
the devices they have are all
top of the line and droid phones.
They have,
you know,
these all these beautiful android devices
like the Samsung Galaxy s four s three
fucking HTC one.
They have the HTC one black.
If you're looking sexy and you need
your phone to be black and mysterious,
or the ht one red,
if you're flamboyant,
you're just a wild child.
You can't be held back.
They have the Motorola Moto X,
which is a bad ass device.
Um,
I've,
uh,
I've been really interested in that phone.
That's,
there's all these new phones that they're
coming out with these android phones
and they're coming out with
them in a much more rapid pace.
Then,
um,
a lot of the other providers like apple,
you know,
apple with their five s you silly pitches.
Can you give me a big screen?
You're fucks.
Come on.
Seriously.
Gimme a big scream.
Um,
I know ting was going to have,
they had the iPhone for a while.
They have it anymore.
Hmm.
Smartphones,
let's say two,
two,
two.
They have the HTC,
uh,
eight x t,
which is a windows phone.
Um,
I have not fucked with windows phones,
but I have a friend who loves them.
I don't trust him.
I think he might be one of those dudes,
some of those people,
and not saying there's anything
wrong with windows phones.
I'm sure there are bad ass,
but there are people that
I think you know them,
we all know them,
that when they have something
they want other people to get it.
Like I had a friend and he
had this old piece of shit,
weird fucking stuff.
This is a long time ago.
It was like,
um,
I think it was a Sony
cell phone and it had a,
it had like a,
like,
like a little pencil that came with it,
a stylist and he would write on it and
they would recognize his handwriting and
it's a fucked,
I mean they're barely
recognized it and it was,
it had all these like really wonky,
shitty apps.
It would crash on you,
but he was just ranting and
raving about how great it was.
Then I saw the motherfucker three
months later with an iPhone.
I was like,
bitch,
what are you trying to do?
You fucking tried to sell me on
the same shit that you're on.
It's like people that are on sprint,
they want you to be on sprint.
People are on at and t like you needed,
you didn't need,
but people who are on ting or on tin
because they're saving money son,
they're saving themselves some shackles
and they're trying to set up a cell
phone company that does it ethically,
that gives you great service,
doesn't give you any contracts.
You can cancel anytime
you want and as I said,
if you don't use all of your minutes,
they will knock you down to the
lower rate and they will credit you.
Ting is a mobile service that makes sense.
It's a no bullshit mobile service company.
They use sprint credit,
new services,
no add on charges,
no mysterious line items for your bill.
You ever get a bill and you're like,
what is this fucking service fee,
Kim?
All that creepy shit the big companies
do to try to extract money from you.
Tank's not about that son.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save
$25 off of any device or service.
So go there,
check it out and I guarantee
you you will enjoy it.
It is an excellent company.
We uh,
we give them a full recommendation.
Brian has been using Tang for for quite
a while and one of the things he notices
when he went out of town,
he went to Canada.
You use tango internationally.
He saved a shit load of money compared
to our friends who used a other less
scrupulous services.
So go there,
check out all the bad ass cell phones.
Like I said,
I'd like the galaxy s four.
You can get the s four purple if you're
a big prince fan or you can get the
galaxy note to titanium.
Chased us to tow crazy.
These phones go there.
rogan.ting.com and now I'm with a
big thank you to the syfy network.
Uh,
I really enjoyed working with them and I
really appreciate the fact that they're
allowing us to release these podcasts.
They were very cool.
It was very cool.
They want to put the show on and a
to we slammed it together so quickly.
Uh,
short notice though.
So,
uh,
thank you to them and a thank you to
everybody over at Arthur Smith as well.
Thanks to frank and Michael and,
and Todd and all the cool
folks that we worked with.
So,
uh,
with that,
with without any further ado,
this is a one of many of the Psi Phi
podcasts for the Joe Rogan experience.
They kiss you on the Joe Rogan
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night all day.
So the Joe Rogan experience podcast,
it's not real.
We're pretending that it's real.
Only 10 carefully,
properly.
Joe,
you should go to Canada.
I heard there's a hum there.
Get the fuck out
and cut.
That was perfect.
Okay.
So there's a lot of people that believe
that the government not only is capable
of manipulating the weather,
but does manipulate the weather and we
know that they've done certain things
like we know that people can make it
rain and not just at a strip club,
but people can make it rain by spraying
certain chemicals into the clouds or
seeding clouds,
child seating.
They have actually done that
in the United Arab Emirates.
They've made it rain 50 times last year,
so they do it basically once a week.
But this is I,
this is,
I've heard it's dangerous.
Like the chemicals that come
with a rain are poisonous.
Oh,
right,
true.
I don't know.
Well,
it's weird.
Chemicals sprayed out of an Arabs jet,
not,
I don't think weird.
Let's
say cloud cities that you never in human
history has anyone flown over a desert
and sprayed chemicals into a cloud?
It's
okay.
Let's find out.
Is Cloud seeding harmful?
That's what a lot of people want to know.
Duncan Trussell.
And when studying the efficacy and
consequences of cloud seeding experience,
the experimenters tend to be biased
towards saying cloud seeding with silver
iodide enhances precipitation
without negative consequences.
However,
much of the literature substantiates that,
not only does cloud seeding fail
to achieve the desired effect,
it also yields harmful consequence.
Also look up that guy eight silver iodide.
If you ever got a turn purple.
Yeah,
that blueberry man.
Yeah.
What happened there?
You eat silver.
These people eat silver out of some.
They think it increases their longevity
or their virility and it makes them turn
smurf blue forever.
Hmm.
So this is one take on it and
there's other takes on it.
That's the problem with the Internet,
right?
Is that if you really wanted to,
you could find a bunch of people that
agree with you and just hanging those
circles.
It's the beauty of the Internet and
it's the problem with the Internet.
The fact that there's so
much information out there,
but if you choose to,
you can filter it down and get it to a
point where you're not really listening
to anybody other than people
that support your point of
I don't need the Internet
to help me figure out if I
want to stand under a cloud
pouring silver iodide,
crystallized rain and into my yard.
Like if someone gave you a choice,
do you want to stand in a rain shower
of PuroClean Hawaiian water or would you
like to stand in a silver iodide rain,
shower and joy,
those relaxing silver particles
spilling into your skin?
Well,
here's the other side of it.
They can also prevent it from raining.
Um,
the,
we know China did that
during the Olympics and uh,
other than preventing
rain for the Olympics,
it says here in this article
on space-explores.com,
whatever it says here in this article
that other than preventing rain for the
Olympics,
China is spending 60 to that other
than preventing rain for the Olympics,
China is spending 60 to $90 million a
year on cloud seeding to provide enough
water for its enormous population to
clear away smog from heavily polluted
areas.
So that's their way of dealing with smart.
Hey,
do you think we should like put mufflers
on our cars now let's just make it
rain.
Just wash it.
Oh yeah.
Just push it down into the corner.
Dyed water.
Good.
It's really good for pollution.
China is going to give China is
going to birth the Godzilla there.
Fucking around with that.
We can't say that it would beep it out.
No,
I yeah,
I yourself God damn it.
I think that's a powerful weapon though,
man.
It really is.
If you want it to attack a country
and you could make rain stop.
Yeah.
Then you would have full
power over that country.
If you could control their weather,
you've definitely would win.
And then the question is,
if you could do that,
how do you know you can do that?
Well,
you'd have to try it.
And how did you try it?
Did you try it just during the Olympics
or did you know about it beforehand?
Have you been using it on countries?
Have you been aiming it in places?
Like how do you do it?
You have to,
is it very specific or you know,
can it be,
can
you misfire and it is,
people can get cotton drive by accidental
cloud seatings where it would rain in
a place where you didn't want it to rain.
That doesn't even make sense.
Dry by accidental cloud seeding.
It ricocheted stray clouds.
You get Ma'am got hit by a stray cloud.
That would be a great dramatic get hit by,
he made it rain on my family.
I'm not even a crip
now besides the chem trail issue,
which,
uh,
we've,
I've met with a bunch of people so far
on this camp trail issue and there's
certainly some,
there's certainly some possibilities
that the government at one point in time
has sprayed something
from a plane for sure.
Sure.
But the idea of this constant
spraying and this in the skies,
the idea,
this constant spraying and this guys
seems to be much more ignorance than
anything else.
I agree.
Yeah.
And not just ignorance,
but like on purpose,
like being willfully ignorant,
like not looking at any of the things
that refute the things you're saying.
It's scientifically people with no agenda.
Instead looking only at
the things that support it.
Well,
you know,
confirmation bias,
it's like pure and simple.
And there's people that
make entire documentaries.
This guy that I met with,
this guy,
um,
Michael Murphy,
he's got these two documentaries.
What in the world are they spraying
and why in the world are they spraying?
And he refuses to look at anything
that points to the fact that what he's
measuring when he's
measuring like aluminum,
he's saying Lloyd's,
look,
we found aluminum and this water,
what he's measuring his dirt
and dirt is rich in aluminum.
I mean it's,
it's a real simple stuff,
right?
So that in saying that this is a part
of some nefarious plan and some secret
thing that he's uncovered
is being ridiculous person.
Also,
I like to think about the specifics
of the person flying the plane that's
apparently dropping the poison onto there.
It's like who are these mysterious pilots?
Did they have breakfast with their family?
Do they sit down and chat about how,
yeah,
going to spray aluminum
dichloride over New York,
honey.
And the other thing is
it's so nonspecific.
I mean everyone down there is the
enemy or everyone down there has to be
experimented with including billionaires,
bankers,
politicians,
they're all getting sprayed on everybody.
Really.
What kind of asshole would do that?
That's the real question.
And not only that,
what a shit result like
it barely does anything.
I mean stop and think
about all this spring.
Imagine if you had something where you
can spray this guy completely cover the
sky in this spray,
this chemical spray and what does
it do to the people down there?
It makes prince freak out.
It makes prince freak out almost worth.
We got to pull that up.
Pull up prince talks about chem trails.
This is a very important,
actually put,
it's a youtube video.
Prince talks to Dick Gregory
about chem trails areas.
It's hilariously awesome and it,
it,
it highlights a lot of people's
ignorance about this issue.
Like they haven't even looked
into what creates these clouds.
And this was a paper that
was published by the,
uh,
the United military in the 1940s,
and they didn't call them
con trails back then.
They called them persistent condensation
trails and they were trying to
determine that these clouds they
were making with propellers.
By the way,
if these clouds,
whether or not they were dangerous
and the same conditions were always
discussed,
it's always like super hazy.
And it's at a point just
before clouds are created,
like a point in the,
the condensation of the atmosphere
where it's almost cloudy.
It's just kind of hazy.
And when they cut through with a plane,
it creates artificial clouds.
And when people saying
they're spraying clouds,
no,
they're actually making clouds by
driving through it with a plane.
I mean,
it's really simple stuff.
Yeah.
I,
I've never really bought into that stuff,
but I have had somebody explained to me
how they're putting poison into the air.
Someone explained that to me while smoking
a cigarette while taking big puffs on
a,
say they're poisoning as a
deadly chemicals in the air,
man.
They just want to control the population.
Yeah.
I've seen people talk about
saving the environment,
whether it drove a Prius and
throw a cigarette out the window.
It's ridiculous.
But you know,
I don't,
honestly,
I don't understand what makes
those things up in the air.
I think they're pretty like
criss crossing pattern clouds.
They're nice to look at it on a picnic,
but I don't think they're poison.
And why is it that they keep
appearing near airports?
That's crazy.
Why would they spray near the airport?
Because that way they could do
it rather than under our noses.
Man.
The biggest lie is the lie that
you don't even have to tell.
Everybody tells us for you ps,
the government could probably release
free packs of cigarettes that say on them,
these make you depressed and people
would just bought willingly buy them.
You don't have to secretly
dump chemicals on Americans.
We're gulping them down every day.
We love chemicals sit in front of a seven
11 and watch those pigs come flapping
out of there with their big gulps
and their pasty glistening sugar,
sugar lips and fried hot dogs.
No,
you don't have to poison a merit.
The idea that you have to actively and
secretly poisoned Americans is insane.
It's ridiculous.
So I think we both agree on that.
They obviously know how to manipulate
weather and they obviously have
manipulated whether before and
by they meaning everyone but us.
Okay.
I don't think you'd done any manipulation
and so we'll just include the whole
rest of the population.
Someone out there has figured out how
to make it stop raining and they've also
figured out how to make it rain.
Yes.
The question is how often does it does
go on and is this a part of our everyday
life that we have to concern ourselves
with and does it spray down harmful
chemicals?
Is the other,
those clouds of the reason why
people are finding aluminum,
the soil,
well it turns out no aluminum is one
of the most common elements on earth.
And it's,
you can find commensurate levels that
they've been finding in these tests that
they've done that prove
chem trails a real,
you find those everywhere
all over the country.
The reason being,
because fucking aluminum is everywhere.
Yes.
Aluminum's everywhere.
So that's something we know
we don't have to worry about.
So we've got that put
us put aside.
So a plane's create clouds automatically
proven be aluminum exists in the
atmosphere all the time.
Proves right.
Doesn't mean that they haven't
sprayed things from the sky.
It doesn't mean that they're not
capable of altering the weather.
We know they are.
Right?
Sure.
But then also isn't there always toxins
coming off of airplanes no matter why
jet fuel that's on fire.
Yeah,
and it's sprays.
And by the way,
that's the one of the biggest
factors in global warming is jets,
right?
Giant tubes filled with flammable dead
dinosaurs that you're flying over the sky
once that spraying,
that's the real spraying.
The real spraying is burning
jet fuel above your face.
Stupid.
Exactly.
That's the poison.
They really are spraying us every
time you fly to The Bahamas,
you're chipping in.
That's what I heard.
I heard every time you fly
your fat kids to Disneyland,
you're incinerating like
19 acres of rain forest.
How do they get to that much?
But I feel I exactly eating a lot
of different ways when I said that.
Now the other aspect
of manipulating,
whether that's fascinating is harp and
I think Harb stands for high altitude
active auroral research.
Let's find that one.
I don't know.
H.
A r.
P just so we know it stands for,
oh,
I spelled it totally wrong.
I spelled it h.
H a r,
which is the Hebrew home
for the aged in Riverdale.
Okay.
Not the same thing.
Don't go there and yell at those
people for controlling the weather.
Jewish elderly people
are making it rain and
they don't even know what you're
talking about and they will hit you.
Okay.
High frequency active
auroral research program.
Yeah,
and this is a fascinating thing because
what this is the official use of harp is
that they,
they send these radio waves up into the
ionosphere and they can manipulate it,
and by manipulating it,
it can aid in communication.
They could shut down communication and
they could possibly make it so that they
can send radio signals and receive
radio signals from very far away.
What's the ionosphere?
The ionosphere?
That's a good question.
We should get the official
explanation without me
going into my pseudoscience.
Okay.
Here we go.
It's the layer of the earth's atmosphere
that contains a high concentration of
ions and free electrons and
is able to reflect radio.
So that's the ionosphere.
So it makes sense that
they would have these,
this gigantic radio array antenna ray,
and that they're sending these charged
particles up into the ionosphere and that
what they're trying to do is manipulate
it so that they can use their radios
more effectively.
However,
the conspiracy theory and the conspiracy
harp has been blamed for a variety of
different events,
um,
including numerous natural disasters,
tsunamis.
Some people think they can cause
earthquake and some people attribute it to
something called sky quakes.
Have you ever heard of sky quake?
Now listen to this.
Okay,
we're gonna play this for you.
This is an audio of a sky quake.
And let's play.
Let's play the one from Allen,
Texas.
There's a bunch of people that are
standing outside and they hear this,
and the freaky thing they say is that
when they hear these things that you can't
pinpoint where they're coming from.
They're just coming from the sky.
And in order to have something that's
that loud that doesn't dissipate with
distance,
you're dealing with some
incredible amount of energy.
And the big F is as if this isn't a hoax,
right?
You could get some Dick heads in college
and think it's cute to just stand
around and go,
what's that sound?
What is that?
And then they go on their computer
and add in some sound effects.
Yeah,
just slow down a trumpet and
put it your picnic video.
And suddenly you've got 15
billion hits on Youtube.
Yeah,
exactly.
And again,
it's one of those things,
it's like what exactly
are we listening to this?
It sounds cool.
Oh,
I didn't know this is called sky quakes,
but I have heard of this.
And what I really like is the Judeo
Christian explanation for what this is.
Because in the book of revelations,
they talk about how the horsemen of
the apocalypse blow these trumpets.
And that's how you know
it's the end of days.
So this is really feeding into the
apocalyptic Christian theory that we're at
the end of the world.
And these are the sounds that you hear
before the great plagues come rolling
through the land.
That's what a lot of
Christians think that.
Did you ever see Kevin Smith's movie?
Red State?
Ah,
yes,
I did.
Amazing movie.
And remember the end when they played
the trumpet and that's what got the crazy
evangelism and make it to the end.
I was drunk,
I fell asleep.
It's worth a second look.
Um,
now we also have some recordings of what
harp actually sounds like in operation.
And this is equally freaky.
It's not a good sound that
you never want to hear that.
You never want to be out on your porch
with your dog throwing a stick and you're
like,
what is what?
So what is hard?
What do they have?
Like demons yelling in a microphones.
I think it's the garbage
disposal of the universe.
That's what it sounds like.
It sounds like a garbage
disposal and space.
No,
this sounds like interstellar locust
descending on the,
when you really stop and think about
the fact that there's something on earth
that shoots energy up into
the sky and makes that noise.
Yeah.
And then above us,
what?
What is it shooting into the ionosphere
where there's like thousands of
satellites and space
junk flying in it just,
no thanks.
No thanks to creeps were a creepy species.
Can you imagine if if chimpanzees were
blasting the honest fear with devil
screeches,
we kill them,
wipe them out with him.
Two days there'd be no more chimps.
We found chimp with a bow and Arrow
would shoot it right in the head.
You'd have to,
you'd have to.
Yeah.
So this,
what's interesting about this is it
like Robin Hood and make a ton of money.
We had this guy on the
show that I interviewed,
his name is woody Norris.
He's this genius inventor,
a true bonafide genius.
He's responsible for over 80 patents.
He is a an audio expert and he listened
to the sounds and review the amount of
power this thing puts out
and he believes that this,
this array of antennas absolutely
could be responsible for those sounds.
And he thinks that it could be responsible
for manipulating whether it can,
that you could have a lot of what you
would call off label uses and that maybe
it was an issue initially created to
heat up the ionosphere so that they could
send radio signals.
But along the way they
might've figured out,
Holy Shit,
we can make trumpets blow
in the sky over Iran.
You know?
I mean,
do you know how freaky
it would be is like,
you know,
you get an email from the president,
good luck,
fuck face,
we're going to war.
And then he had a raw,
you'd know it's common and
you hear trumpets in the sky.
Just that alone is like,
listen,
we've been thinking,
we've been very hasty.
The nuclear who needs nuclear power?
My friend,
he stopped the trumpet.
Japan has problems with it.
So we don't want that in this world.
No.
You know what,
man,
I think that for whatever reason,
it's part of the government's job to
every day come up with new ways to kill
people.
And someone looks at tornadoes
when tornadoes hit and thinks,
wow,
that would make a great weapon.
If I could figure out a way to do that,
I'd have the ultimate weapon.
Because the problem with nuclear bombs,
aside,
aside from the fact that they like
kill hundreds of thousands of innocent
people,
is they irradiate where they hit.
So you end up not being able to move into
that area as a good conquer would want
to.
Cause everything's full radiation.
Everything's like Chernobyl.
So you know,
and with bioweapons the same thing.
Well that was the hydrogen bombs.
That was the idea behind the hydrogen
bomb was that you could kill everyone
there.
But leave the structures.
Yeah.
Can you imagine that pitch
meeting where somebody,
he's like pitching that I've
innovated something great.
We can leave the structures
and kill all the people.
Great Gym.
But with this,
with this idea,
it's sort of like a in between thing,
which is that not only could you send
in tornadoes or earthquakes to wipe out
populations,
but also you could do it anonymously.
No one would even know
who is doing the attack.
You would just think you were having
some bad geological luck for a few years
until everything's flattened.
And then the UN comes in.
It's like,
well look,
we're going to help you rebuild.
And then the next thing you know you've
been infiltrated by the empire taken
over and you don't even know it.
It's the ultimate weapon.
So it makes a lot of sense that a,
that a government or an empire would
want to investigate this stuff.
Absolutely.
And if this was a possibility,
they would certainly
explore it and look into it.
The real question is
have they ever used it?
And that's the beauty of this thing
being sort of an anonymous thing.
If you really can create a storm,
how would you know that someone created
a storm or whether or not it's just a
storm.
You,
you,
you send a nuclear bomb,
there's an obvious footprint.
There's sure you know where it came from.
We know a human created it.
They,
they connect the dots.
They find out you can't,
like,
it's not like throwing a snowball
in a car and running behind a bush.
When you,
when you throw a nuclear bomb,
you get caught.
Every,
everybody knows you're an asshole.
You don't need Colombo to solve that one.
[inaudible] question is,
do you think that they've done it already?
That's the real question though.
The question is not,
can they manipulate the weather?
It's been proven.
Can they manipulate with harp?
We don't know.
But if they could have they already,
yeah,
just I,
I think so.
I,
yeah,
sure.
If they could,
if they could,
they've definitely done it.
Do you think that they
could do it with harp?
I think harp is creepy.
I had never heard those sounds before,
but I've seen that array of,
um,
uh,
antenna and there's spooky looking.
And also I heard that security at harp
is like area 51 level security and I've
also heard that they don't,
they're very,
very secretive about
what's going on over there.
So I wouldn't surprise me if
I had something to do with
controlling the weather.
That doesn't surprise me at all.
I don't know.
I would hate to break up with someone
who worked at Harv is reigns over your
house for a year straight.
It's just always cloudy
in your neighborhood.
Well,
let's listen to what some experts say
because a Stanford University professor
[inaudible] said to popular science
that weather control conspiracy theories
were completely uninformed
and he explained that there's
absolutely nothing that
we can do to disturb the
earth's weather systems.
And even though the power that
harp radiates is very large,
it's minuscule compared with the power
of a lightning flash and there are 50 to
a hundred lightning
flashes every second harps.
Intensity is very small,
but he could just be a shill.
Who knows?
He could be working for the man.
Who knows,
man,
I to Stanford teaching all those liberals.
He's a lot more credible
than some hipster.
And a fedora with a beard
yapping about tornadoes.
Are you a hipster?
Officially?
I don't know,
but I mean I could be called
wine and I get judged like that.
But again,
who knows?
Man,
I,
I just think that the government has
explored in governments of the world if
explored how to kill people and almost
every possible way from coming up with
weaponized smallpox to
using nuclear bombs.
So why wouldn't they explore it?
Something like the weather,
it makes a hundred
percent absolute sense and
you no one else for sure.
This Omran in non is
not hanging out at harp.
Okay.
He's not going up there.
He's not talking to those scientists.
He's not absolutely clearly informed
as to what they're capable of.
Right.
And there's one thing that really smart
people love to do and that they love to
dismiss things that they believe are
silly or things that don't agree with what
they've stated.
Yup.
And so a lot of these guys that are
saying this like computer scientist David
Nadick who characterize harp as a magnet
for conspiracy theorists and says that
harp attracts their attention because
it's purpose seems deeply mysterious to
the scientifically uninformed.
He says that.
But when you talked to
geniuses and experts in sound
and in the power output and
they talk about the,
uh,
the capabilities of a
system like harp there,
like you're talking about something
that's being run by Darpa,
right?
Yeah.
That's,
let's pull up.
What does Darpa stand for?
Cause I think it's something evil.
It's definitely something evil.
The defense.
Advanced research projects.
Agency defense.
I mean maybe that means defense as in
they need to charge up the ionosphere
descend radio signals or maybe it means
that a sound robot in the sky is going
to eat your baby.
Absolutely.
And have you seen that other crap
Darpa spits out of their health,
those robots that you can kick and they
don't fall over deadly galloping dogs.
Weird springing attack.
Frogs death drones.
Like of course they're trying them
and have their own Twitter though.
Oh,
follow them right now.
Bam.
The official Twitter
account for the defense.
Advanced Research Projects Agency follow.
They have 50,000 followers.
Sure.
Wow.
How many of you have 75
you have more than Darpa.
That sad suck at Darpa.
Yeah,
that's what I say.
Fuck off Darpa.
No,
I love you darling.
Would like to come work there.
I'm going to Alaska and a
couple of weeks to do stand up.
I want to visit.
Do you think they'll still let me in?
Yes.
No,
no.
It's like the one of the most
secure places on the planet.
They let you in.
That's one of the saddest things when you
run into like any of these people that
you've villainized and you're,
I was like,
yeah,
come on in.
Check it is thing out.
We've got,
yeah,
we're just trying to make
radio waves work better.
Yeah.
And then you leave and they laugh.
They turn back into reptiles that fuck it.
I got his phone.
Let's follow home kills dog.
Dog died of a heart attack.
Well,
you know,
yeah,
yeah.
I,
you know.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know.
I didn't.
So there's some things I've learned today.
I didn't know that harp was run by Darpa.
I had no idea that there was any
connection there because I said that.
But let's make sure that that's correct.
Harp run by Darpa.
I think it's true.
High Frequency Dee Dee,
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee,
you n the defense.
Yep.
Okay.
So that's pretty weird because Darpa is
a notorious creator of things that are
without question going to
destroy our civilization.
They just gleefully
whip up death machines,
um,
without any concern for what's
going to happen 50 years from now,
sort of.
Or maybe they just make good
defensive stuff to keep the defense
defense.
Offensive Defensive Department of Defense.
Yes.
It about Dunkin and keeping us safe.
It's about the defense.
You know what neat about
offense being offensive?
You know what made me feel really safe?
Uh,
a galloping robotic dog,
they can chase me over may or
may not have cannons on it.
Galloping dog that's half made of c four
that makes its way into your building
and then makes a volcano explodes.
I felt so scared.
I used to be so nervous.
I'd walk around with fear inside of
me until those packs of wild galloping
Cyborg dogs made solar
powered dogs and by the way,
they could be solar powered.
No,
ain't just to run all day.
It never rains here and
they can be autonomous to,
or they're just controlled by 18 year
olds and trailers outside of Vegas with
with Xbox controllers all
messed up on government speed.
Yeah,
look at a speed that they give
those those drone operator.
He makes sure they're
hopped up on the good stuff.
If you want speed,
talk to a drone operator,
they've got the good stuff.
They don't need big gulps.
I didn't even drink water.
They just have a pace to their chew on.
They don't,
they don't take in any moisture.
Moisture disrupts the
effects of the electrolyte
imbalance that math provides.
Darpa in the Internet because I
think Darpa invented the Internet.
I thought Al Gore did
a,
I think Darpa did invent the Internet,
which is going to create a thank you,
right too.
E
involved in the creation of the
Internet and history of the Internet.
Formal group with Darpa,
the fruit.
A group within Darpa.
Huh?
Brief history.
Then in 1973
okay.
Yeah.
Well,
here's what's interesting.
[inaudible] Darpa is also linked
to the creation of the Internet,
which is fascinating.
In 1973 the US defense advanced
research project agency or Darpa,
initiated a research program
to investigate techniques
and technologies for
interlinking packet
networks of various kinds.
The objective was to develop
communication protocols,
which would allow network computers to
communicate transparently across multiple
linked packet networks.
So it was created by Darpa.
The very thing that will bring
down the empire was created by it.
Well,
see,
that's what I,
that's what happens to all mad scientists
is their creation turns against that.
So true.
Frankenstein.
Yeah.
It was killed by Frankenstein.
It's an inevitability.
It is,
isn't it?
Yeah.
So this thing that,
so they unleashed the internet.
Who knows what else they've unleashed
or they're going to unleash,
but you know what else?
The Internet did inform people about
mushrooms maybe that can help them with
Darpa needs mushrooms.
That's what they need.
Imagine the kind of shit that you could
create if you had the technology and the
resources of Darpa.
Yeah,
but it was all people on mushrooms.
They're beautiful world.
It'd be amazing.
Think of what burning man would
look like if Darpa took it over.
They would kill all the
people begging for sandwiches.
That'd be the first thing.
Take him outside of we know how to do it.
Them like they didn't even care.
Even if they're on mushrooms and
just still just shoot hippies.
Let's tell you,
just knew you did that.
Come on guys.
Stop crying in.
Know that brother was a loser.
You brother had dirty feet.
Come on,
come on.
We shot him.
What's the big deal?
I got more mushrooms.
Who wants to sing?
Who wants to get in a drum circle?
Drones that shoot poison darts at
anything that smells like Patchouli.
Some hot girls.
It's more like a truly a lot.
A lot of hot girls.
Some girls,
they were like little oil.
Just as a gentle like I look very oil.
Mm hmm.
I love that sweet smell up at
Julian and I body the sweet smell.
But truly and bumper stickers.
I like the sweet smell of it,
Julie,
cause there's usually
like good acid around.
Now here's the other thing.
Here's the other thing that people
think a harp is responsible for.
There's a thing in Windsor and
it's called the Windsor Hum.
And these poor people that live in this
town that's across the river from Zug
Island,
which is near Detroit.
And these poor people
that live in Windsor,
they say that their houses rattle their
windows rattle and sometimes it's 24
hours a day.
Just whoo,
whoo,
whoo.
That's how they all describe it.
And no one can seem to
locate the source of it.
Some people say that it's coming from
Zug Island and some people say that even
though you can't hear it near Zug island,
it gets more powerful.
The further away you get.
And they describe it as like a
tsunami effect that like a tsunami,
like it starts in one place,
then builds up powers.
It moves along well.
If you talked to anybody
knows anything about sound,
they say that's not how sound works,
but they seem to describe it that way.
They just scream seem to describe it as
a sound that's coming from a place where
they can't quite pinpoint where it is.
They want to say it's
coming towards Zug island.
But some folks say that as
you get closer to Zug island,
it actually is less noisy than it
is when you're further away from it.
It's a really weird thing and it's
not one person complaining about this.
You're talking about an
entire town of people.
We talked to several people,
not one of them was like,
what are you talking to?
Does anybody live on Zug Island?
No.
Zug Island
is gross.
We went to visit.
Sounds great with such a beautiful name.
Who would think that it would be gross?
Zug Island stinks.
It smells like pollution.
You could buy a house across the
river from Zug island for 500 bucks.
That's how bad it is.
So there,
so what you're saying is
there's this low resonant hum.
I'm merging from a place called Zug island
and would Zug island is for,
it's,
it's it cross from Detroit.
It's a part of Detroit and it's for you.
They make steel there and they have these
giant piles of raw materials and these
furnaces.
And we talked to a guy named
Gregory Fornia who worked
there in the 1960s and it
was,
he said it was always disgusting and it
was always dangerous and it was always
environmental hazards.
This is really,
really polluted.
The river around there is one of the
10 most polluted places in the United
States,
and yet people are fishing
there and pulling fish out
left and right where we're
there.
So it really kind of scary stuff.
But he,
he said that what they're doing,
they're a wood they've always been doing
there is manufacturing steel and he
believes that that sound is
just a part of the process,
the,
the process of creating and making steel.
Sure.
That makes sense.
It does make sense.
What doesn't make sense
though is the sound itself,
when you bring the sound to
sound experts and you say,
is it possible that this
sound was recorded six miles,
five miles?
Is it possible?
This sound was recorded x amount of miles
away from a source and was this loud
in a person's house and they say,
no way.
We met a guy in Windsor named Gary Gross
and Gary recorded some sounds that he
says are the winds are home.
All right.
And listen to this.
We're going to play it for you.
Huh?
The imagine being in your house.
Okay.
And there's something here like this
and he is miles away from Zug island.
I mean,
it sounds like you're
outside of nightclub.
It sounds like high powered bass speakers.
Huh?
Inside a building.
Except there's nothing near him.
He's just in his house and everyone
in his neighborhood feels it as well.
So you're not talking about something
that's like a car that has giant speakers.
It's right outside your door.
And that's why you hear this.
We you're talking about is something
that somehow or another is making these
people's houses vibrate
like this from miles away.
We don't know of any kind of sound
that can do something like that.
What is Woody's last name would,
wouldn't even Doris.
Nobody.
Not Worries.
When we played this
sound for Woody Norris,
who is a an acoustical expert,
an engineer,
brilliant genius.
He said,
there's no way the industrial
process could make this sound.
He said that the amount of power that
would be required to make a sound like
this that would travel that far and
not dissipate in the environment is
incredible.
Yeah.
Now,
is this something that
has been documented?
Yes.
The sour,
the sound has been documented.
This sound has been documented by
the people that live in the town.
It's been documented by the politicians
that try to get the explanations for the
citizens,
but if this is a sound that
is emanating from Zug island,
it would have to be
insanely loud on Zug island.
What people are saying though
is that when you're around it,
when you're in the river,
it's not that loud.
It's when you get further away
that it's doing things like this,
that it's vibrating people's windows,
vibrating their houses.
There's no known explanation for this and
when I talk to this guy who's an audio
expert,
he says that in order to create
a power output like that,
you're talking about an insane amount of,
yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
No that's,
that's an,
that's a really,
really intense sound and it'd be a bummer
to have to deal with listening to that
because that is a depressing sound.
That's a sound like in my
neighborhood when that sounds starts,
you,
you're not sleeping that night cause
someone's having some idiot party until
4:00 AM it sounds like a party.
It sounds like bass
speakers it sounds like,
but that would be like your neighbor.
You would have to be like really
close for that to be affecting you.
Like
I'm just saying that as a weapon.
If you wanted to,
if you were experimenting with weird
forms of weaponry and you could blast that
sound over someone that you were fighting
or someone that you wanted to disrupt,
that would do it because
that is not a pleasant sound.
Right,
but that I don't,
don't think that that's
what anybody's claiming.
I think what they're claiming is that
this is a side effect of the use of this
technology.
Ah,
and that most likely what Zug island is,
is some sort of a repeater and that
these people are experiencing the sound
outside of the island because of harp.
How close is that to harp?
It's very far from harp,
but what they're saying is that Zug
island could be a repeater station.
And the other thing
about harp is that harp,
although it's really far away,
the whole purpose of the magnetizing
the ionosphere or a rather,
um,
uh,
charging the ionosphere shooting these
waves into the ionosphere is so that they
can transmit long distances.
So what the conspiracy theorists believe
is that Zug island is some sort of a
repeater station.
So these people who live in Windsor across
the river from Zug island are getting
this crazy sound echo thing going
on that's rattling their buildings.
No one can explain it.
W W shaking their windows.
I mean,
these people have really freaked out.
And again,
it's not like a couple
people we're talking to.
Is this always happening?
It happens quite often and
it's dissipated apparently.
And that's where the heart,
the heart proponents believe that what's
happening is that they've realized that
they're making the sound now,
so they've turned down the power out.
I don't,
I don't buy it,
man.
I think if you're dealing with like this
super advanced Darpa project that can
shoot out,
uh,
things,
the ion is fear.
They're not going to be like,
hey,
let's turn Zug island outside of Detroit
into a bass speaker so that everyone
can freak out.
No,
that's not what they're saying.
They're not saying that
they're doing it on purpose.
What they're saying is this is a side
effect what they're trying to accomplish.
Right.
I don't think anyone is saying that those
sky quakes or something they're doing
on purpose.
What they're doing is they're doing some
sort of experiments and in doing those
experiments,
one of the side effects is this
very strange sound phenomenon.
We're going to go there
and see and investigate and
talk to some of these people
and find out if this holds up.
But it's a very interesting possibility
and these sounds are very unique.
And you know,
very ominous and weird.
Yeah,
they're definitely weird.
I just,
I wonder about the Darpa connection,
but if you go there and
actually hear the sound,
I'll be more likely to believe it.
It's the kind of thing where if I knew
someone who'd actually heard the sound
themselves,
then I don't know.
It just,
this seems like it seems so easy to fake.
It seems so easy to drop these
kinds of things into sound files.
Okay.
Totally.
I totally agree.
The thing is though,
the,
the compelling thing is
that all of these folks,
it's well documented that these
people have been complaining.
In fact,
when I went through customs,
the guy asked me,
what are you here for?
And I said,
I'm a here to listen to some hum.
And he goes,
oh,
the winds or hum.
Like he goes all,
I go,
what is that?
He goes,
it's probably something
going on at Zug island,
like right away the cop that
works at the border tells me,
do you feel,
did you hear it?
No,
we didn't hear it.
But we heard a lot of industrial noise.
Right.
And it didn't sound anything like that.
What we heard is like call out are
clanging and trucks moving and stuff.
Is there any got like one going
on around there or any of them?
No,
no.
That stuff's mostly done on Canada.
Huh?
This is what they,
what they're doing there is they're
just creating steel and they're a,
they're mixing the,
the raw elements to create,
create steel and their furnaces.
And there,
there's some,
there's a lot of industrial stuff going
on there and it's very high security,
but the high security can easily be
explained in that that steel and make,
creating all that steel is very important
to the industrial output of the United
States.
It's,
it would be,
uh,
if you were looking for a place
to disrupt our economy or to,
to mess up,
you know,
an area that would be
something that would do it.
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
You just mentioned that
you didn't say there.
It's a high security area.
I think that's really weird.
If this is just supposed to be
some toxified industrial island,
I think there is something
suspicious about the therapy.
Uh,
the combination of a massive amount of
security around a polluted island and
some bizarre Godzilla noise
rising up out of the nothingness.
That does seem to indicate that
there's more going on there.
Then just making steel.
You're right.
It's very possible.
However,
it's also very possible that what you're
dealing with is a high security because
they're creating steel there.
It's incredibly dangerous that
working with volatile materials,
they're also probably doing a lot of
environmental damage that they wouldn't
want people to investigate or people
to shine cameras and expose all this.
I mean it's stinks there but when you
go there the water is like greasy with
whatever the hell they're leaking into it.
The guy that we were with
was Taz that it floats green.
There's like this glowing green shit
that you see in the water so it's not
healthy.
It's definitely,
it's definitely stinks.
It's definitely bad.
We,
we were thinking while we were there,
like were breathing this
hand like this is like we're,
we're,
we're taking it fumes.
Yeah.
Detroit is a crazy place man.
When I went and performed at
Mark Reilly's comedy castle,
awesome spot.
The Guy who drove me there,
he told me that he used to buy
eight balls and go camping,
like who does cocaine camping?
Kid Rock.
Yeah.
I don't think he could blame
Detroit or Zug island on that,
but I feel you.
Yeah.
Detroit is the worst person
in the world to be a book.
That's the worst place in
the world to be a book.
There's 47% illiteracy rate and they
call it the first American ruin.
Yeah,
because there's so many at
parts of it that are just gone.
Dude,
across from Zug island,
you can get a house in
Detroit for $500 we saw them,
they were telling us about
it and we saw amazing.
It's incredible.
And you don't want that house.
Well,
no.
It's got toxic mold and it's next to
the moaning of Baphomet and the smell.
The smell is horrible.
The smell in the air is,
it's really a shame.
It's a shame.
I know you need steel.
I know that they need it,
but first of all to do it right there
in a highly populated area like Detroit
and to do that kind of
damage to the environment.
It's just sad.
It's sad,
it seems archaic.
It seems like some shit that they should
have figured out how to do better a
long time ago and it kind of makes
sense that if you're disrupting the
environment at that level in someplace,
then there's going to be unexplained
side effects like some odd noise.
I don't think that is the case.
So this is the thing.
I don't know whether or not the noise
and the industrial output or connected.
It makes sense when you look at the sound
and the sound is coming from this spot
and you look at the spot and
it's a lot of machines moving.
There's a lot of digging in the ground
is a lot of making steel Aquaman's razor
would dictate that sound is
probably coming from there,
but if these people are to be believed,
these people that are talking about this
sound and the rattling of the houses,
it's too much power.
It's too much power.
It's too far away and it's too strange.
It doesn't seem to make sense.
And would it could be is that
we're connecting these two,
these two events together.
Right,
but they're,
they're not connected and that all those
Zug island is a place where they make
the sound where they
were creating or rather,
although Zug island is a place where
they make steel that this noise is not
emanating from Zug island,
but in fact it's coming
from the sky itself,
from harp.
It's just that people are assuming that
Zug island has something to do with it
cause Zog islands gross so
that it's just a coincidence.
Super Creepy.
It is creepy.
That sound,
that sound is real is very creepy.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
But you have a good point too,
is that we didn't hear
that sound and unless,
unless you,
even if it was like
someone you really know,
how do you know whether or not they're
really recording that sound or whether
they're getting wacky and getting on
their computer and creating it and say,
I'm going to freak everybody out and I'm
going to bring some more cause or more
people to this cause more,
more eyes and ears to this plight that
we're suffering here when really it's
just normal industrial noise that
people are complaining about.
You gotta go there and see
and if there's the site,
if you hear the sound,
which I bet you won't,
then it will be interesting.
Why do you bet I won't,
man.
Maybe I will.
Okay.
I don't think there you,
I think the sound of Zug island is the
sound of people's neurons frying is they
smoked Detroit level crystal meth in
the basements of their $500 crap homes.
Whoa,
whoa.
That's the sound of your brain
rotting inside your skull,
bouncing back and forth
off the bony walls.
There it is.
Imagine though,
if you were in your house
and you're hearing this,
it would be the most annoying thing ever.
And these people say that it could be 24
hours a day and then sometimes they'll
get up in the middle of the night to
pee and then we'll hear that sound and
they'll never get back to bed.
They also said that for some reason
it seems to correspond with the rain.
They said when it's stormy and rainy,
sometime there's,
there's that sound.
That is where the heart people come in
because they think that that's not a
coincidence and they think that the rain
itself might be rained that was created
by harp and that that's why these people
are saying that whenever it rains and
your thunder,
that's when this sound is more prominent.
Wow,
that's crazy.
It's crazy.
As symptom of whether being controlled
by harp is low resonant sound sky quakes.
But that makes sense.
Sound.
Think of that.
It's raining out and you hear this
sound and you know that big brother is
fucking with the sky and making it
rain above your shitty $500 house.
Uh,
that's leaking.
Is it bad enough that I'm here breathing
in toxic farts and living in a $500
house.
You guys got to shake my three remaining
windows with your stupid sound.
All I want to do is smoke my mat in peace.
There's a physicist named Brooks Agnew
who says that he can demonstrate the
effects of harp in a box that he's
built and he creates artificial clouds.
He is like one of those MREs.
You know how you buy like a bonsai tree
at the mall and they have like the fog
that's flowing out of those are beautiful,
right?
Well that stuff is very similar to clouds.
That vapor,
that water vapor and
they puff out at clubs.
Yes.
No,
that's,
that's a smoke.
That's the shit that
Michael Braverman likes.
He likes to put that when
we're doing promos a fuck,
he likes to fill the air with that shit.
You know.
I love you buddy.
Um,
no.
The um,
it's actually,
uh,
it's vapor.
It's water vapor,
but this guy claims that he,
this device
that can create the same sort of effect
by charging the particles that are
inside of this,
this box that he built,
he can actually prove the effects of harp.
Well,
he's saying that there is a correlation
between the e cigarette smoke and his
box and actual clouds.
Well,
what clouds are,
is vapor.
It's moisture and it's in
a condensed sort of a one.
I should probably actually
have a technical explanation
because I just ventured
into bullshit.
I do that.
I felt myself doing it,
but I pulled back what a
cloud is and I'll never,
I have no idea what it is.
A visible mass of liquid droplets or
frozen crystals made of water or various
chemicals suspended in the atmosphere
above the surface of a planetary body.
Okay,
so now you know,
so it's,
it is clouds with his guys creating as
essentially the same thing as clouds.
He's using moisture and he's using
this machine that does something and it
creates e-cigarettes,
e-cigarettes,
or an ionizer that creates water vapor
that has nicotine infused into the vapor.
Just like Stephen Dorff.
Awesome commercials.
Now.
Hey guys,
come on guys to take back our freedom
saying that if this is like if a giant
Stephen Dorff,
we're breathing east segregate
cigarette smoke over America,
it would be cloud.
And if you had a machine you could zap
that the clouds and make a tornado that
take Stephen Dorff away like the house
and the wizard of Oz where it lands on
the witch.
Yes.
Just like that.
And then Darpa would finally have
done something amazing for the world.
That would be the second best
thing they did since the Internet.
Look,
Stephen Dorff was awesome and blade.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you need to step.
I stepped played one
is the best blade ever.
Stephen Dorff was the,
the the bad guy and he was amazing.
She's amazing.
Great.
So shut it.
I'm sorry Steven to laugh.
Please apologize.
He's too easy.
Stephen Dorff.
Steven making our cloud.
Stephen Dorff is the Nickelback of actors.
It's too easy to pick on him.
It's not fair.
It's rude.
It's cheap and it's rude.
He's the rape joke of actors.
We just need to stop.
He just stopped the Stephen Stephen
Dorff happened to be flipping through
channels right now and heard
that he's going for his pistol.
Well don't shoot me as long as
you going to shoot yourself.
Death is inevitable with my friend.
Okay,
but murder,
you don't want to murder
charge like yourself,
Steven,
don't do it.
You're going to be fun.
So look,
I don't,
I think that it's a interesting thing.
I the box.
I would wonder if the clouds in this
box are identical to the clouds.
It they are actually floating overland
because I think like what you just did
definition that you just read it.
Ice Crystals,
chemicals.
This is just like ionized vapor.
So I wonder if it looks like it's
actually better liquid droplets.
It's a visible mass of liquid droplets
or frozen crystal sugar water.
So it's close enough
for various chemicals.
Like there can be a toxic cloud too.
That's not not water droplets.
Chemicals can actually form toxic
clouds.
And he's saying that by shooting
some form of electricity into this,
this is what he says.
So we're going to say,
and we're not going to
say we've already seen,
so we're going to change shirts and
we're going to go right into this because
this guy's an idiot.
Okay,
awesome.
So I go to visit this physicist named
Brooks Agnew and Brooks Agnew has a box
that he's got this artificial clouds
that he's created with this Mr Machine.
Yeah.
And he believes that he has this
machine that can dissipate the clouds.
So we go and do the experiments.
First of all,
here's red flag number one.
We walk in the door and his friend,
uh,
there's a photo of a,
an Indian man with
white paint on his face.
So I say,
what's up with this dude?
And he said,
he went,
underwent an amazing transformation
of his body 10 years ago,
and now he no longer needs food or water.
And I go,
no,
he didn't.
And I just walk out of the room.
I go,
no,
he didn't.
He goes,
you have to meet this guy.
Go,
no,
I don't.
No,
I don't have to meet him.
And that guy eats,
stop,
get away from me.
And like I knew right away we'd made a
horrible mistake cause this is the dude
he's partying with.
Okay.
It's not the scientist
and the scientist buddy.
Okay.
So we go in that Brooks has this machine
and in this machine he's got the clouds
and he's like,
no,
I'm going to turn it on.
And so he turns it on and uh,
we're,
we're seeing the clouds dissipate
fairly rapidly and we're like,
hmm,
this is interesting.
The clouds have dissipated fairly rapidly.
But then we noticed this motherfuckers
got a crack in the door so the clouds are
sneaking out of his door.
Okay.
So now we take over
the cracks of the door.
We turn it on again.
Now this,
it doesn't dissipate at all.
Right.
It's just sort of hovers there.
But there's some weird
funnels like coming off of it.
Well,
it does seem to have an effect.
Well then we opened the door
and touch it and it's hot.
So this stupid machine that he claims
is changing the ionosphere and the tube
and then making the weather manipulate.
It's just hot.
It's just a big stupid hot electrical box.
And when it gives off heat,
heat rises and it,
you know,
it goes through this stupid fake clouds.
So nothing so not,
but here's what's crazy.
Not only did this guy thought this,
but that this guy thought this enough
to build a machine and that he did this
and said,
this is so good.
It needs to be on TV.
Yeah,
that's fun though.
Going crazy.
I'd love to go that crazy.
Do you know how fun that would be?
Seriously constructing a
weather machine in your house?
Yeah.
That will be a blast.
So he's enjoying life and he somehow his,
whether machines summoned the TV crew
and you know what's really crazy magic.
He's a white guy.
Hello?
Who'd a thought it's,
you never see white guys
with these unfounded claims.
It's a really rare that you see a bunch
of white guys in their late forties
early fifties possibly into their
sixties hosts divorce or post divorce,
just eaten alive by depression.
Like,
yeah.
You know,
waking up and spitting out pieces of
their teeth from grinding all night long
and then going to work on your weather
machine is your tears disrupt your
experiment when you contemplate how your
wife left you because you wouldn't stop
talking about harp.
And then you call your friend over the
Tarion who knows a dude who actually is
an heir at Terrion.
Just each air doesn't have water,
doesn't have food that makes sense to you.
This is the guys hanging out
at your house and you go,
what do you think you to
help me put this together?
I think you're onto some amazing work.
Amazing.
You're doing amazing work.
So they put together this stupid
thing and it doesn't work.
And,
and you flew out to that?
No,
I drove.
This was an,
luckily it was in California,
but not only did we drive,
but this is how stupid we are.
The Guy said there was a mistake
with the experiment we want.
He wants to do it again.
So he had them do it again.
So the,
the camera crew went back a second time.
And guess what happened the second time?
Fucking nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
Nothing's going to happen.
You knew nothing was going to happen.
You wanted the camera back again like you,
this guy probably has seen the secret
like a thousand times and he thinks that
if he really truly believes
that this is a weather machine,
then it becomes a weather machine.
Yeah.
Or something.
By the way,
the next season of this show,
you are going to be riddled with trolls.
Who realized that you guys
will come out to anything.
It's too late.
What do you do?
Just email the Scifi channel and
Joe Rogan shows up at your house.
If you've farted in a box.
Dude,
it's way too late for that.
Did you see the photo that
I tweeted yesterday of me,
uh,
with this stupid fucking
apparatus on my head?
Cause some asshole claims that this
stupid apparatus was going to uh,
detect electricity that
comes off of my eyeballs.
Look at this.
This,
this fuck had gotten me to where this,
this guy got me to wear this.
And inside this thing does goggle
inside the goggle is like a sensor.
And the sensor reads the electricity
coming off your eyeballs.
So he's talking to all these scientific
terms and he's got a degree in Canada.
And so he tells me he's,
he tells me that this device measures
of the electricity coming off your
eyeballs and that theoretically you could
feel this electricity on the back of
your head scientifically explaining the
psychic phenomenon that a lot of people
believe in,
which is that people can tell when people
are looking at the back of their head.
So this fuck head gets me
to put on this stupid thing.
I got glue all over my head.
Lucky I'm bald because then
I just have to clean my head.
If that was in my hair,
I'd be pissed.
Especially if had some beautiful like
Joey Lawrence and the nineties hair,
just something flowing,
you know,
and then saw this gooey shit.
A boy can dream.
So anyway,
I got these goggles on and the goggles
have a sensor in and he shows me that on
this EKG.
So what it's called Eeg,
Kanji,
whatever it's called.
He shows me EEG.
Electroencephalogram.
Yeah.
He shows me on this computer that the e
g f set up is reading all the electrodes
on my head,
but also reading the one
that's in front of my eye.
And then it's a very similar signal,
thus indicating that electricity
is coming off of your eyeball,
like the evil eye in scientific form.
So,
so,
um,
I say,
hmm.
So I look at his test and I go,
did you ever try just
putting it on your hand?
And then I just put it on my
hand and it's the same thing,
this same signal.
And the only time it's not the same
signal is when it's shaking because I'm
going,
it's the same fucking signal you made
me put glue on my head and I'm holding
your wacky space goggles that you
think can measure eyeball raise.
You'll fuck head look
what you've done to me.
I'm mad.
And I said to him,
I said,
how did you get again,
same thing.
How did you get on TV with this?
How did it Kinda does and how has this,
not just a dumb idea that you fucked
around with with your friends,
but you got so far that you
went to her producer and said,
well this is what I can do.
And he went,
I like your Moxie.
I think this is going to really happen.
I think this is going to be an amazing
segment once they show that you are
correct and that you can shoot raise from
your eyes and then I can detect this,
oh this is going to be fantastic stuff.
You could probably be on
Doctor Oz after this show.
Wow.
But no,
it's just another white dude with
unfounded claims in his 50s and access to
aluminum foil.
He had aluminum foil and head glue.
Has anybody looked into the correlation
between starting to like aluminum foil
and going insane?
It's like cats they make out of,
I mean that's literally wear tinfoil
hat theory came from somewhere along the
lines.
So many fuckheads had tin foil hats on,
but people actually came
up with that expression.
Like if you say that expression,
the tin foil hat brigade,
people know exactly what you're saying.
You don't have to say conspiracy theorist.
He say,
oh,
he's one of those tin foil
hat wearing motherfuckers,
and then the conversation's over.
If you aren't using
aluminum foil for cooking,
there's a 15% chance
you've gotten and saying,
what is,
what is it about aluminum?
And that's the shift that
people look forward to.
It's,
yeah.
I can show people that always
claiming this plane aluminum.
It's all aluminum with these guys.
You know what's crazy is the
ground is mostly aluminum.
A lot of God damn aluminum up there.
Apparently it's super cheap.
Jamaica
is a source of aluminum.
Jamaica is a source of aluminum.
Yeah.
They put,
well,
it's apparently according to scientists,
it's one of the most common
minerals known to man.
It's also what you put into an apple.
If you've lost your pipe,
you can smoke weed from
an apple on aluminum foil.
Aluminum foil pipes.
Yeah.
That's the foil though,
buddy.
It's not the same thing.
It's a mineral that's in the ground.
You're talking nothing crazy.
Foil isn't made of aluminum.
Yes,
it's made of aluminum.
I don't want to talk about it
too long or we'll both go insane.
If it's aluminum foil,
just aluminum or does it have anything
else that's mixed into it and heat it
down?
It's kind of fascinating that they can
make metal that you can just repeat here
is the downwards slippery slope.
Well it's kind of cool.
Aluminum foil is cool.
Like you could take an ass hole and
you could wrap that apple up in it.
Like did you take a piece of food and
wrap it up in the internet or a friend?
Turn her under an android.
Don't do that because chicks are always
going to think that you really want an
android and then we're
going to make them insecure.
I do it to ever make a
girl do dress up bro.
Who says
like,
I tried to take away your
favorite thing in life.
Go like,
who the fuck are you?
It's like saying never
put salt on French fries.
How far do you take dress up though?
Do you take it all the way to furry?
Like at a certain point in time?
It's weird.
Like there's a certain amount of dress
up and this society that we allow,
like you're allowed to wear a toupee
through the metal detector at the airport,
but they will make you take
off a fake beard if you have,
like if you've walked through and you've
got to look at Abraham Lincoln beer
with a chin strap and they're looking
at you like we can get this motherfucker
this,
you know,
like a little tie behind your head.
A big stupid fake beard.
They're like,
you have to take that officer.
They'll allow you to wear a toupee if as
long as it's like pinned down somehow.
Oh,
once how K to finds out about that.
They know now it's over.
There's a certain amount of dress
up that you're allowed to do.
Sure.
Right.
So you are allowed to wear a ball gag,
but you can't dress like a mascot.
You know I'm not,
I'm not against of,
but I'm saying you can't
be a furry me know anybody.
If you're a furry,
if you'd like dressing up like a mascot,
open up the front hatch and
having sex with each other,
you fucking crazy.
Right.
If you're someone who likes to dress up,
like a girl likes to wear leather
or she likes you to tie her up,
she's just a freak.
But if she wants to dress like bugs
bunny and she wants you to come and her
face,
that's crazy.
That's a friend.
Yeah.
What is,
what are the fuck is the
furry thing with the mascot?
I don't know.
That is,
that is really creepy in the furry
stuff I can kind of understand,
but like it's when people are like
putting like holes into their e or stuffed
animals and fucking them
where stuff gets weird.
Yeah.
That gets really weird.
Like a fleshlight in the
giant Barney the dinosaur.
Thank you so much for tuning
in to Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
We're going to cut to commercial.
Well,
this is going to be
released as a podcast too.
That's what we're doing.
We're taking an audio form of this and
we're going to put it out as a podcast so
it's,
there's no,
nothing will be lost here.
Oh,
that's exciting.
Yeah.
Great.
If TV was advanced enough to recognize
that no one's being offended anymore by
anything.
Yeah.
Right.
At a certain point in
time they would have to,
well,
they have to accept that when podcasts,
I'd having the same exact commercials
and they're pretty close is television
then they're going
to have to accept that.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
And,
and I,
I,
I can't wait for African
Mama in their hand.
You know,
I just,
uh,
heard Al Madrigal actually,
did this interviewer,
they asked him what his least favorite
song was and he said that Macklemore song
about thrift shops and he said,
the reason is like,
it's like having to explain to your
daughter what jizzing is or what,
you know what I mean?
Like when your kids listen to it or
like there's apparently a song in the
Macklemore's song about pissing on,
uh,
what's is it,
who's the rapper?
He pissed on the 15 year old.
I have no idea.
Kelly R.
Kelly.
There's apparently some reference to
our Kelly and the song and magical is
pointing out how like it puts you in a
weird place when your kid is asking who
are Kelly is and why they're talking
about him pissing his bed or what?
Well,
why?
That's ridiculous.
Why is he playing that kind of
music around his fucking kid?
His kids.
Kids love it.
Kids listened to that.
How old are his kids?
I don't know if they're young.
If they're under 15 they're young.
That's rude.
Well I think kids can get to this music.
It's not like you're,
you're playing it for them.
It's like they find it.
They find it online.
Yeah.
Like,
like,
like my,
your dad's porn.
Right.
It's not like your dad's like come here,
look at this pussy.
It's like you found the porn.
Right.
So kids find that's a PR.
I mean I think his point.
What apps to a strip club w with
thrift shops would that have to do with
sheriff's house?
What do you mean?
That's the name of the song.
The name and the name of the songs.
Thrift shop.
It's just,
he made the point he made that.
I thought it was interesting.
It's like,
yeah,
I guess if I had kids it would put me
in a weird predicament if I'm always
having to explain to them like adult
concepts cause I have to either decide
between lying to them or
like telling them the truth.
And that's a weird place
to get into with a kid
and the now in 2013 that's not really
necessary anymore because by the time a
kid gets to be 13 years old,
right,
they've seen it all.
Yes.
That's true to me.
Remember how much shit you saw
that your parents had no idea.
Like did you ever see any
like faces of death stuff?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean we saw a lot of shit that you,
you didn't,
no one ever saw before us.
Well yeah,
right.
But we never see,
I mean the stuff that kids
are seeing now is just,
yeah,
we were the first generation c we
were the first people with VCRs.
See our,
our family,
like our parents did
not grow up with VCRs.
Right.
So when they grew up,
either saw something on TV or you didn't
and you didn't get to see it again.
If you don't,
the only time you saw it again as if they
played it again and they never played
anything again.
They'd played a few movies like every
now and then they'll take King Kong is
going to be on again.
You'd know when you'd wait for it.
Right.
They have to watch it as it was happening.
So our generation was the first
generation that had tapes and we would get
something and stick it in something
and press play when we wanted.
So we were the first people to,
to take that next level
information thing and right.
And what did we do with it faces a death
barnyard Betty like some of the most
fucked up heinous things ever.
Like within a few years
of making VHS tapes,
they had a whole series of faces of
death and that's when the UFC came out.
And like all these different
things like the early UFC is,
we're like that.
Like a lot of people thought that was
what you were watching wasn't a martial
art.
They thought what you were watching
was just like some faces of death type
thing.
Like,
oh my God,
but watching cage fighting.
This is crazy.
It became a martial arts.
Sure.
Beginning.
It was like more of a
freak show than anything.
Yup,
but the kids today,
that's a,
that's a joke.
The kids today,
like a beheading.
What is that?
That's another thing I heard
that foreign yard Betty
for teenagers,
anal sex is second base.
Like they're fucking each other in the ass
soul before they're having vaginal sex.
No.
Yeah.
That's like a night of making out.
You probably end up sticking
your cock and a girl's ass.
No.
[inaudible] are you doing this and what
it on a chat room or is this is when it,
whenever someone says to me,
the teenage kids,
teenage kids are having
more anal sex than ever.
Yeah.
I always say,
why you even research and teenage
kids and angels and anal sex like,
oh,
let me Google search history.
Five years.
I didn't pop up once.
Ain't kids and anal sex kids.
Only if we had this conversation.
Teenagers and anal sex.
Those are kids.
If you Google search
anal sex teen right now,
you will get more results
than moon landing.
I think they mean like 18 and 19 but
that's not what you mean when you're
talking about kids.
We're not talking about porn.
You're talking about kids and having sex.
Here's a real shocker.
14 high school.
Let me just send a bolt of
terror through the country.
Kids are fucking in highschool.
Guys knows I did.
You people are not ready for this.
You should slowly work this in.
Yeah.
You shouldn't just say,
Hey,
guess what?
Your kids are fucking,
what if someone's been in denial?
What have they just been in denial?
Just Holman Christian songs as they walk
around the house thinking the kids at
school,
just learning.
Meanwhile,
she's just someone's balls deep in
her ass and a dumpster right now.
Yeah,
they're hide behind a cardboard box.
She's getting fucked so hard.
She's using telekinetic to like live cars
and that sound is the Windsor
hum is filling the sky.
Oh.
Her eyes are rolled behind her head.
She's squirting.
Oh
yeah,
whoa.
Got squatch all over go watch.
Yeah,
well that happens man.
Kids are fucking,
my mom bought me a box of condoms
and now he's in the 10th grade.
She gave me a box of condoms cause
she knew I was going to be fucking,
she's like,
just wear these condoms.
She'd seen my girlfriend.
Well she knew your
girlfriend was a dirty girl.
Not just dirty,
but like albino is like swampy.
Like she was like that.
You should have to wear it.
Come on now.
I know.
In the swamp.
That was your first girlfriend.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God.
Albino and swell.
That sounds like a Stephen Lynch movie.
David David Lynch.
Stephen Lynch is a singer.
Ah,
that is a David Lynch.
Movio translucent skin blue vein.
Listen,
a swamp.
Blue van.
[inaudible] long cliteracy you don't
know whether you say something or not
that's going to deal with this.
It's just,
it's not
quite a finger,
but I mean it's definitely a finger
that's been bitten off like a nub.
It's enough.
I wouldn't say it's a finger.
It's like a finger that lost a bar fight.
When do you talk about the
length of a girl's clutter?
It's like what do you think immediately
after you get done fucking her to your
friends?
I mean if it's,
it depends on how big it is.
If it's totally normal,
it never comes up.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I've never discussed the length
of my life by my wife's cliteracy.
You should totally normal.
I'll tell you right now,
there's nothing special about it.
It's a regular vagina.
It looks great.
It's awesome.
Great good design.
You don't need to fuck with it.
It doesn't need pin stripes,
but the,
the crazy ones,
the ones that are weird,
it's like what is that like why is there
an evolutionary advantage for looking
like a Mousse with a gunshot hole in it?
Oh his.
What is it about?
Is it about some of them
that vary so widely,
but at least with a woman like it doesn't,
I don't think they vary so much and
well I guess they do vary in size,
but it doesn't have any like social
stigma attached to it and in fact have a
girl has a,
a very small and a welcoming tight little
area that's probably better than a big
crazy loose thing.
So it works the opposite for
them than it does for us.
For us,
it's as evolutionary advantage
to have a large penis.
I see what you're big Rasputin looking.
We looked at Rasputin's yesterday.
We were looking at it.
Oh yeah,
I've seen Rasputin's cock jar.
I heard his story that Rasputin was at a
bar and telling people that he was rice
Buton and they're like,
whatever,
you're not recipe it.
And he's like,
I'll show you I'm fucking recipe.
And then he like pulls his job
tree trunk cock out and like,
yeah,
you're,
you're Rasputin it's in a jar.
It's 11 inches soft.
It's a big jar too.
It's like that would not fit in
a regular mayonnaise size jar.
Costco Jar.
Yeah.
He would have to get a Costco Jelly bean
jar if they have a special caulk jar.
It's just for Cox.
I said,
yeah,
but his cock was like,
that is a,
that caucus is a bad thing.
Like it didn't,
that cock is a um,
uh,
a death hammer.
Like that's a thing that you can even
still now it's how ever many years it's
been in that jar.
You can still feel evil coming off of it.
Yeah.
Maybe you can feel evil.
I feel a bunch of player haters,
a chopped off of giant God's Dick.
Oh wait,
he's just a regular dude with a big deck
slinging dicks are given out bubble gum
and having a great time in Russia,
which by the way sucks.
It's freezing cold.
Everyone's an asshole.
They're all the other ass kicked by the
Mongols and then it never recovered.
So they're up there freezing their
dicks off and one guy comes along just
swinging a monster hog and
having a good old time.
And he hypnotizes all the girls in the
area with his Dick and his Willie ways
and he winds up being a superstar
amongst all of these women,
including the Zarina,
the czar's wife.
He was given the fucking King
of the lands wife the Dick.
That's fuck yeah,
son.
Yeah,
he was hanging around all those chicks.
He's one of those dudes
like Arnold Schwarzenegger.
He's hanging around you.
He's fucked
you.
Here's the thing,
you can't cheat with rescued because
like if you're in bed with your wife and
you look down at her vagina
and it looks like a sink hole,
like you fuck trus fusion,
you asshole like you're hit.
Vaginas would look like craters
after experiencing that.
That this is like,
it's a cock the size of the
width of an encyclopedia.
But regular vaginas have
babies go through them,
which are much bigger than a cock
and I snap like they snap right back.
If your wife gave birth the next
day when you be able to tell dude,
yes,
but Rasputin's Dick was not nine pounds.
I did have,
these are nine pounds,
dude.
Vaginas are crazy.
Oregon's,
they stretch out and pop out a baby
and then snap back shut like a clam.
They don't snap back shut like I am.
It's a slow snapback.
No,
they stitch up stitch up any tearing.
They snapped back like it's
like a slow congealing.
Right.
How do you know now?
I've been through it three times.
Trust me.
My wife's vagina is excellent.
They stitch that shit up there.
There's some tearing
and I think when they,
when they stitch it up,
they have that Benny Hill music plan
because they know that
you got to do it again.
He's just going to get pregnant again.
What would that one more time.
All right.
Damn man.
It is weird though.
How nature did didn't build in the,
uh,
it's weird that that's,
that there is a tear.
It's funny that it's,
it's not built so that it just pops a
baby out without there being damaged or
pain.
Well,
that's how chimps do you ever see
chimps give birth now pull up,
see if you could see a chimp giving birth.
See,
we've got a video online.
The way chimps give birth as they just
reach in and pull it out and that's it
and they're done.
They just reach in,
pull the baby out,
put it down,
clean it off a little bit and they don't
come out helpless either mean obviously
they need their mother
but they're not like us.
We come out like incredibly
help us for a long time.
We can't even walk,
we can't do shit.
We can't even control our own
heads.
We just fall forward.
We are,
our heads are so big that we have to
be born like way earlier in the process
than other animals and our minds are so
complex that the gestation process takes
a long time here.
What this that's the baby.
She leans back like
she's in an old school,
Traci lords movie and she just grabs a
hold of the hair on the baby and she's
just squeezing it out.
It doesn't seem like
she's in any pain at all.
And she's,
she just squeezing on her very casual,
her vagina and a,
the baby heads is slowly popping out and
she's just trying to figure out when to
get a grip on it and the males
coming over to check it out.
There's no doctors,
not a sanitary environment.
I terrible mural,
not a Filipino lady to be seen.
Try going to a hospital
and not seeing a Filipino.
Good luck.
I don't know why,
but that is true.
They just make awesome nurses.
They're drawn to hospitals like math and
she's like sitting there while this a
baby's coming out of her body.
It just,
the,
the evolutionary process is so strange
and when you see like a life coming out
of a life,
it's one of the weirdest things you get.
I've seen it several times now.
You know,
twice in person and it's a,
it's a trip man.
It's really a trip.
I'm assuming that's her mate,
but I don't know like the
other ones like watching,
he's concerned it's insurance.
She's most likely a whore and she
probably fucked every champion the whole
group.
But she's just trying to look at this.
Wow.
She's,
she's just bending over and he's
checking it out now and she's like,
what do you see?
Flexible.
Yeah.
She's like,
what do you think?
Is it ready?
And he just know,
hmm.
Wow.
And she's like,
it's so weird.
Like I'll get it now.
She's squeezing them out there.
Whoa.
This is crazy plot.
Oh Damn.
That needs to be an animated Gif file.
Like the moment the baby comes out
and the puddle that creates and the,
the,
the male is it?
Of course she's eating the placenta,
the ether percent there.
Right away.
I've heard that you should do that.
That is a fucking trip.
That is it.
Such a trip.
What's really true and so sweet.
They're both licking the little chin.
What's really a trip is
that chimpanzees are a,
some sort of a distant relative of us.
And at one point in time,
our ancient ancient ancestors would
probably very similar to this and that
something happened and we kept
going and we went from that to this.
Well,
that that seems a lot,
a lot sweeter and more natural
than doing it in some sterile room.
People wearing weird clothes.
Well that's not sterile.
I mean that's not natural.
That was in a zoo,
dude.
That was on a slab of concrete.
How,
how natural is it for a chimp
to give birth on concrete?
Absolutely.
Right.
I don't know why I said kind of fucked
up about the baby coming out on that hard
surface.
Like if they were in jungle,
the jungle
soft.
It's like when we were in Seattle
looking for big for it to set the ground.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's very soft.
Like you could shoot out a
kid there with no problem.
Yeah.
If you heard about the father
Zod and the source family,
do you know about this?
What father's Od and the source
family and the source family?
I can't.
It's a cult and I can't remember
if it's Manson or father's side,
but in these calls,
you know the lemon,
of course they give birth
after they get impregnated.
Right.
And this guy,
as I recall,
I'm trying to think of it's Manson.
I got my coat leaders make step.
I can't remember which one but in one
of these look up father Zod umbilical
cord,
that classic search
we NSA is knocking on my door as we speak.
Please.
Hmm,
no,
it's just as documentary where it's,
it was the point is that a woman gave
birth and I can't remember if it's Manson
her father's out,
but one of them chewed the umbilical
cord off like bid it bit through.
It is probably your father is odd
cause I never heard that story.
Yeah,
it's father's Zach because
you'd hear about it with Manson.
It was father's out,
but it kind of makes sense.
You know
now looking at that video of that
chimpanzee given birth on the floor,
that zoo like seeing that animal,
how alien that is to you or I,
but not that much.
I mean it is alien,
it's an animal.
But it's kind of human like
and a lot of ways sure.
Aware,
intelligent,
paying attention to what's going on,
you know,
and the,
the two arms and two legs thing.
Yeah.
It's so similar.
So it's so strange and it's so strange
to think that somewhere in the past
that's if you believe in evolution,
which you shouldn't,
but that's somewhere
in the past allegedly,
we were something like that
and that we were all sort of,
uh,
developing along a similar line.
And one of us became,
you and I,
one of us became a Homosapien,
became a human being.
Right.
But there's other ones.
This is the Homo Floresiensis,
that little hobbit man
and the island of Flores.
Yeah.
There's neanderthal.
Notice how I said tall
because I'm very educated.
I thought,
no,
that's the old way I'm current.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I how I judge a man by the way.
He pronounces neanderthals.
You're tall.
You're kind of an asshole.
I'm an asshole.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
That's how I'm Anderson.
Cooper says neanderthal
because you're right.
God dammit.
I'm getting neanderthal
southern wrong with that.
The underdog.
It sounds better.
Anyway,
over the job
I would have Flores,
ma'am,
it's a three foot tall hobbit man.
Really fascinating thing that
until a few a few years ago,
they thought it was just horse shit.
They really had no idea that 10,000 plus
years ago there was this little tiny
man running around and running around
the same time there was grown humans like
you and I like or rather our size.
Um,
even though we're both short the,
um,
the question has always been,
are there others?
And the question always been if
there were others,
where the fuck would they be hiding?
Right.
If there's an aisle,
well,
they didn't find out about gorillas
and to the early 19 hundreds,
but the deal,
that's sort of a disingenuous
thing to say though,
because the world of the 19 hundreds
doesn't even remotely resemble the world
that we see today.
Right.
Because the world that we see today,
we,
we pretty much have a good account of
what's alive in almost every place.
Absolutely.
Might've missed a few spots.
Like there's some weird shit,
like every now and then they'll find like
a weird frog and New Guinea or a D in
Vietnam.
It's been hiding in the
jungle and they're like,
whoa.
But where people are not willing to
go is with another intelligent animal.
You could say you found a
previously unknown deer in Vietnam,
which did happen recently.
Sure.
A couple of years ago.
In fact,
big animal,
like a size of a whitetail deer,
completely different species
they weren't aware of before,
but it lives in the jungle and you go,
well,
I could kind of see that happen,
but the idea of an intelligent thing,
that's where people won't budge.
The idea of an intelligent ape like human,
like thing,
another branch on the evolutionary
chain of lower hominids to human being
another branch.
Yeah.
It's interesting how in the
news when you hear about,
they discovered a new
lizard in the Amazon.
It's like,
oh,
whatever.
Who Cares?
I'll think about that for four seconds.
It's not interesting at all.
I don't even want to
look at a picture of it.
Right.
But if they came out and said,
we found an intelligent apelike being
living in its own civilization and the
depths of the rain forest,
that would make news forever.
Yeah.
So change the world.
Yeah,
we're,
we're so,
it is interesting that we do,
it's not a surprise any other species
that gets discovered out in the great vast
wilderness that still exist,
but for whatever reason,
we immediately disregard the idea that
there could be another form of super
advanced primate.
Others.
And they found primates very recently.
In fact,
they found this little pygmy primate.
It's a little tiny little monkey thing.
It's really small though.
So we don't really give
a shit about it now.
It's like,
so what?
You found a tiny monkey,
but if you found a seven foot tall monkey,
they would go ho Lee shit.
What is it
that if it didn't,
they just fine,
but didn't they just find
something akin to that?
Like,
didn't you?
Uh,
what did you call,
it's called the shit.
It's some very rare carnivorous apes.
Yes.
Pull up an image of the Bondo ape.
You could see one that got shot and
you can see this animal and this is an
animal that,
um,
up until I think 1996 they
didn't have any photos of it.
There's a wildlife photographer from
Switzerland named Carl Armand and Carl
Armaun went to,
that's a really old picture,
right?
Isn't that a picture from like the
early 19 hundreds it could be a,
I think that is,
I think that was a picture where it was
a huge chimpanzee and they didn't know
why that,
that,
that chimp was,
was so big.
That's the one that got shot.
Now this is a,
a chimpanzee that's way larger.
The other TV doesn't work.
Yeah,
it's off.
Okay.
For a reason.
Yeah.
Okay.
That CBC,
that thing.
Yeah,
but you can just look at it,
man.
No,
you don't have to look at it.
See,
you can see that thing behind you.
Just look at it and just
this not looking for happy.
That's like,
you don't want to stumble onto that thing.
They shot it,
but that's that.
It looks like a gorilla.
It doesn't look like a chimpanzee
and it looks like a gorilla.
And it's called the Bondo ape,
and up until the 1990s
this thing was just a,
it was a myth.
It was a legend.
It's an enormous chimpanzee
and the locals in the Congo,
they say there's two types of chimps.
There's the tree beaders and the lion
killers and the tree beaters are these
smaller chimps that who
swing from tree to tree.
The lion killers are these bondo apes
that are giant champs that sleep on the
ground like gorillas.
Right.
They're not scared of anything.
They sleep on the ground.
They didn't have to hide in the trees.
Like to this day,
the reason why people have their
master bedroom on the top floor,
it was the whole,
the whole chimpanzee idea,
or you get to the the highest branches
where you're the most protected and
that's where you rest.
That's crazy.
I never knew that,
but yeah,
you're absolutely right.
What the house,
it's at the top of the building.
That's the best part of the building.
Just the leopards can't get there.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That is crazy.
Well,
these animals that are so big
that they're not even scared,
they don't go to the top of the tree.
So probably the branches would break
cause they're probably several hundred
pounds.
I mean the,
they're not like a small chimpanzee.
You mean they're like
three plus maybe even four.
Right.
So you're dealing with an enormous
chimpanzee that occasionally will walk
upright.
There's phone,
there's a camera trap photo of one.
So if you can pull that up though,
Karl Armaun camera trap chimpanzee,
you can see this thing walking
upright and they're six feet tall.
Right?
It's enormous.
So you're talking about chimp,
that's four inches taller
than me and it's huge.
Just gigantic muscles.
Probably as strong as all
like a thousand pound man.
Yeah.
And they got a video of
one eating a fucking leper.
And here's the important note
in relation to Sasquatch,
they just found the thing,
1990 you have a six foot
chimp that walks up right?
Wandering around in the,
in the,
in,
in nature.
And no one's discovered it until just now.
No one's gotten proof of it till just now.
Yeah.
Look at this thing.
This is the picture of it walking.
It's walking upright.
That's a shit resolution.
It's hard to see in that photo,
but that thing is walking hunched over
and upright and it's six feet tall.
Those are devil chimps.
Their heads look like skulls.
Look at their heads.
They were enormous.
Well,
they have a crest on their head like a
gorilla that the only other chimpanzees
and the only other a
primate besides gorillas,
they have a crest on their head like that.
So they thought initially before
they ran DNA tests on them,
they thought initially that they
were a hybrid between a gorilla and a
chimpanzee,
but now it appears that it's just a subset
of this chimpanzee if he's a species.
Yeah,
so to me that that is one of the things
that exist in the world that made me
think it's possible that there is a Yeti
or a Sasquatch because w how could you
not discover something that's that size,
that that is that unique?
Why wouldn't,
if something like that can hide from
modern society for so long after the
invention of cameras,
after the invention of helicopters,
then why couldn't there be something
like a Sasquatch or a Yeti or something
like that?
Still out?
Yeah,
they're,
yeah.
They found the gorilla,
like we said in the early 19 hundreds.
It didn't find this for almost
a hundred years after that.
Right.
And we know the chimpanzees
are intelligent.
We,
but we also know that they're not
nearly as intelligent as people.
I don't know if that thing was hiding
from people or it was just in a place that
was so remote and so hard to get to.
The Congo is enormous.
Right?
I mean,
it's really impossible for us
to wrap our heads around it.
It's like almost as wide
as the United States is.
It's huge,
I think is that they're correct.
Google that place.
Um,
it's,
it's enormous.
It's,
it's many,
many,
many millions of square miles.
Right?
And so the,
it's not without outside the realm of
possibility that this almost impenetrable
jungle can hold a bunch of
different animals in it.
But the difference being this animal
looks like another animal that we already
knew about.
That's why it's not that crazy.
Right?
Big Foot is a totally new thing.
You know,
you're saying there's an animal
that no one's ever found.
Look at the size of that.
That's the Congo.
Geez,
Louise from top to bottom.
It's almost the same height as,
uh,
as the United States.
That's giant.
And that's all jungle.
So the,
um,
the idea that this is a big foot though,
that's where it gets a real squirrely
because you're talking about a totally
undiscovered primate that lives around
people and gets real close to people,
but never when they
have their cameras out.
Never a picture that is,
are a picture like what you
just showed me at the Bondo ape.
Never a picture or video where you,
it's indisputable.
It's,
it's very similar to you,
fos or goes through any
other thing like that.
It's,
every picture is easily
discounted or at least,
or not quite good enough.
Right?
Not quite good enough.
Every photos like,
man,
that might be Sasquatch.
Alright.
I don't know.
It's hard to tell
[inaudible] not a single camera trap.
Do you want any camera traps are
out there now hunters used them,
they set them up on trails and
they put these things out there.
And what they do is they take a photo.
Either they have two ways of doing it.
Either they take a photo every three or
four seconds or five seconds or whatever
you said it,
four or they,
they act on motion.
So when they see something
walking in front of them,
a flash will go off and they take a photo.
So they will,
it'll deal either be night
vision and the work at night,
or they'll work on a flash system.
Sure.
None of these things
let me ever caught us up
and I play Sasquatch advocate ears,
please.
Okay,
so you've,
you actually pointed out this,
these tigers that were on some other
island that on an island that like evolved
in sense,
it's lions actually.
Why Africa?
So relentless enemies.
National Geographic special.
Okay.
So
why I point that only because
we've seen cases where evolution
happens rapidly.
It doesn't happen over the course of,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of years.
Sometimes it seems to happen in a
really fast way and there would be an
evolutionary advantage for a being
like a Sasquatch to avoid humans.
In fact,
there's an evolutionary advantage to
any creature avoiding humans because we
like to eat things.
We love eating.
Things are turning them into our slaves.
So there's an evolutionary advantage
to staying the hell away from us.
So in that way,
uh,
if a primate somehow evolved in the
same way we did and we've made super
computers and robots and space shuttles,
if for whatever reason,
something similar to us,
wouldn't know it,
a different direction,
which is the direction of being
closer to nature tied into the earth.
Part of that evolution would be
avoiding the crazy ball monkeys.
They eat you,
they enslave you,
they will have sex with you if
they can stay away from them.
So in that way it could make sense
that a super advanced primary,
it will be able to smell a human
scent on a device like that.
And they just stay,
stay away from it.
They avoid it.
Why?
Why couldn't there be some new reclusive
primate animals run away from me all
the time?
It's possible.
It is possible.
And when you say it like that,
you bring up a lot of
not of awesome points.
I mean,
if you were going to be a primate that
was super intelligent and figured out how
to live in the woods,
the smartest thing to do,
it'd be don't let people know
about you ever stay away and mean.
The real question is how
smart are these things?
Now,
if you talk to the,
the,
let's,
let's give a broad spectrum of
wackiness and she talked to the,
for the UFO hunters,
the wackiest of wacky thank their people.
They think that they are the
spiritual beings that are very human,
like inform,
like they think they have a human face
is just a very dark face and that they're
just covered in hair and they were a type
of wild human that lives in the woods.
Okay.
I mean there's,
there's some really,
there's a,
there's a lot of variation in what
they believe that they're capable of.
Sure.
But ultimately they're talking about a
giant bipedal ape that no one's taken a
picture of.
Sure.
It's gets a little sketchy.
Well,
no,
I mean,
again,
to play Sasquatch advocate,
if you look at a monkey jump,
like whenever you see
a monkey run up a tree,
just a monkey.
If you watch how graceful and
powerful those things are,
and you consider you ever being
able to do that in a million years,
you see how much more advanced in
certain ways just a chimpanzee is.
Yeah.
So imagine if something had an equivalent
form of advancement when it came to
being able to camouflage
themselves or to hide,
you know,
maybe these things are just so good at
hiding that maybe the part of evolution
that made chimpanzees able to
climb a tree in five seconds,
and humans able to build
a Chrysler,
maybe that part of evolution made these
beings able to hide and as super skilled
way they can cover their tracks,
they can hide in the shadows.
Why not?
It would be a great advancement for
a being to be able to hide an a.
And w
no,
you're right.
You're right.
You're absolutely right.
A great advancement for a being
to be able to hide though.
I'll say it.
It would be a great advancement for
a being to be able to hide that way.
Yeah.
He pull up a video of bear
runs up tree startles hunter.
You know that video.
This is a pretty famous video.
These guys bow hunting and
while their bow hunting,
this bear just decides to make a
break for it and runs up the tree.
Not that weird.
And you know bears climb trees.
I think we both know,
but did you have any fucking
idea how fast they can do it?
I don't have this fair gets 20 feet up
that tree in a matter of seconds like
this and all of a sudden he's up there
looking eye to eye with this hunter.
Exactly.
I just want you to see,
just to put it in perspective,
let's,
let's look at it just to,
just to get a peek at it.
Watch this.
So here's the guy.
The bear comes close to him.
I don't know if this is the same one.
Did you check this one was sideways.
I was trying it
get something fast.
Let's see.
What do you mean it's sideways?
No,
that one I pulled up.
The video was sideways.
Oh really?
Pull up.
Let me see what the
other video looked like.
Let me say it.
Oh,
it's sideways.
Yeah,
that's the right video.
But does it stay sideways the whole time?
I didn't even bother to look.
Go,
go a little further up.
You might figure out what
the fuck he's doing wrong.
Yeah,
he does.
Now get a little bit further
up and here's the bear.
Now watch this.
Watch this.
Bear move.
Okay.
Give us some volume.
The bears are already up.
Give us a volume and take it to right
when the bear makes a run for it.
So the dude is up in this tree,
Stan,
he puts this food out and the way you f
you hunt for bears and a lot of places,
it's not legal in California this way,
but a lot of places they let
you use bait and buy bait.
The usually mean donuts.
They take a,
yeah,
yeah.
They,
they take donuts or something sweet and
they put them in a barrel so that this
bear,
we'll go to that barrel and then
while he's looking for his food,
that's when he killed him.
It's really trying to do shit.
That doesn't look fun at all.
It's kind of Douchey.
But if I'm watching this bear run,
look at this.
Check this out.
Look,
he makes a bolt for it and
then just put it on rump.
Ah,
watch this.
Yeah.
The guy obviously fucked
with his camera here.
What does that,
this is wrong.
You can show it.
What's wrong with this video?
Is this a bad video?
Why would not say in this?
Okay.
Figure it out.
Something wrong with the video.
That here's,
here's the,
the point is that this
bear runs up this tree.
The way you could run straight,
like he literally runs up the tree.
It's,
it's pretty fucking insane,
right?
This is not the same video.
You can stop now,
but that,
here's the,
here's the essence of the thing.
When you look at a chimpanzee
and you look at a human,
what are some of the similarities?
Well,
the similarities are both have figured
out how to use tools in a rudimentary
way.
Chimpanzees use stakes to get
termites out of the ground.
Humans use cars to get to their jobs.
So,
um,
why,
why is it,
why isn't it,
why isn't,
why isn't there the possibility
than another primate,
instead of evolving the ability to use
tools or instead of just evolving that
ability they used,
they evolved the ability
to camouflage themselves.
Because in nature,
if you're a hunter,
what's a better skill
than to be able to hide?
There's almost no better skill in nature.
Chameleons are almost every
creature that is a predator.
There's skin has adapted to
their surroundings in a way
that makes them blend in
so that they could be a more powerful
and efficient Predator in that way.
Why wouldn't a primate now just evolve
a skin color or hair color that makes
them blend in with their environment,
but the ability to hide and
a true super advanced way.
Okay.
So I'm gonna play devil's advocate please.
And this is not
necessarily what I believe,
but if there was really
an animal like this,
there would be something.
Now all you have is like the theater
Roosevelt wrote about it in a story.
Yeah.
You know about his time,
his time in the woods,
but when a dude gets killed by a wild man,
who knows?
I mean,
who knows what really happened,
right?
And then 19 whatever the fuck it was
back when teddy was running around.
The reality of life today is that if
you're dealing with a very populated area,
everyone has a fucking
camera on their phone.
Sure.
If everyone has a camera on their phone
and no one is getting a photo of this
thing,
how many human beings are traveling
through the areas where these things live
and not one person gets a picture.
And now here's the other problem.
It's iconic.
It's an archetype.
It's a thing that people go to right
away is I think it's very similar to the
gray alien with the big eyes.
Yes.
I think if you are not
sure what you're seeing,
your mind will create this thing.
And one of the reasons that I say this
is because I read a lot about hunting
accidents and one of the things that has
happened in hunting accidents is that
people who are experienced hunters
who know that in order to bag a deer,
you have to capitalize
on a very split moment,
a very small window in time where you
got to capitalize on that in order to get
the kill right.
Well,
people have shot people
accidentally and sworn up and down.
They saw a deer,
they swore up and down
that they saw a dean.
Right?
And when you're talking about big
foot and you're talking about bigfoot
sightings you're talking about,
first of all,
it's not a mystery.
It's not like you're talking about,
you know,
finding Rumpelstiltskin or something else.
You're talking about something that
people have repeated the same stories over
and over and over again.
You're talking about something that
we have a reference to in our heads,
and when you see something,
you might see just a whisper of something
you don't know what the fuck you saw.
You saw something through the
trees and it's dark out there.
Anyway,
busy canopy of leaves
and it's never sunny out,
right.
It's always rainy and cloudy.
So what are you really seeing?
Sure.
But by the time a week goes by,
or a month goes by,
or maybe even an hour,
maybe it takes you three hours to
walk to your car and you're an idiot.
And you convince yourself in those
three hours that you saw his face and it
looked at you and it read your mind.
You might be so pumped up
with adrenaline and fear and,
and,
and who knows?
Just longing for a life with excitement
where you're not wandering through the
woods looking for fucking shadows.
Also,
half the people in the
forest or high at any time,
please stop.
Nobody goes into the,
we can only base that grateful dead can.
We can only base that on our own personal
experience and with you and I was 100%
so it's 100% of the people
in the woods or high.
Yeah.
Cause that's all we have.
We should have got those big foot Chi Psi.
That's where we fucked up.
They were just drunk.
We should've got him high.
Yeah.
Big different results.
I,
I really mean it though.
I'm saying that people go into
the woods and they get hi.
Yeah,
you're right.
If you're going to take mushrooms,
what did people always say?
Go take them and then nature
takes them in the forest.
So,
and that way I would say that a lot of
the observers who are experiencing these
a,
a lot of the people in the woods or
maybe under the influence of Ntl of
intoxicants,
but you don't need to be right.
If I'm a kid out in the woods,
yeah,
I can hear anything,
man.
She thinks you can see things.
Dragons,
big elves.
Yeah.
Cause think of the woods.
There's no light.
Trees are shifting around.
It would be very easy to project anything.
And you know that there's a real danger.
What was that noise?
Hello?
Hello.
There was a real danger.
There's a real danger.
There's mountain lions,
there's bears,
there's wolves.
The woods contain real things that will
kill you and forget about poisonous
spiders and stinks.
There's mountain lions,
bears and wolves and the woods.
So there's a real fear.
So it's a really highly
charged environment.
So what you mentioned earlier,
how people prefer to have rooms on the
top floor of a building or a house.
Examples like that show how embedded into
our species is the trauma of having to
deal with predators in the wild.
The wildness that we evolved in.
So it makes sense that somehow inside of
our neurology is imprinted the remnants
of the these predatorial forces,
the kind of combined racial memory of
all the things that used to hunt us in
Itas and when we,
when,
when we go in the woods,
even today,
maybe our brains still are on alert or
on guard for these things that used to
terrorize our ancestors and people who
see big foot or really just seeing a
projection of this thing out into nature.
It could be that it also
could be a reaction to being
in the wilderness itself,
which is mostly being experienced by
people who aren't native to the wilderness
when they're having these experiences.
Even if they like,
like normal campers,
the camp on every weekend,
they don't live there every day they,
they live there in short bursts and
then they run back to civilization.
So in living in that environment,
there must be some thinking where you're,
you wonder what it would be
like to survive out here.
One,
would it be like to survive
out here without nature,
could an intelligent being do it?
Maybe he's out there.
Maybe my would brother
is out there right now.
My,
my ape monkey would brother
who's just as smart as me,
but chooses to not engage and
remain on the outskirts of society,
eating off the land with
its intelligent mind.
Hiding from people.
Yeah,
it's possible,
but it's not that likely.
It's not likely.
That's what sucks.
But why is it so sexy?
Why is it such a sexy idea?
Why is the idea of seeing big foot
one of the most exciting things?
If you said to me,
Joe,
would you rather be able to fly without
a plane anywhere you want it in the
world for 30 whole days or go
hiking and actually meet big foot?
Wow.
I would say I'll take big foot.
I'll take big foot over
30 days of awesomeness.
What does every great dream?
You're flying,
you're flying and every great dream and
then you land on a girl wants to have
sex with you.
That's what every great dream is,
okay?
This is,
I'm telling you that if you
gave me 30 days of that,
I would say no.
I would rather meet big for it because
I've got some questions I want to know if
it's real
well.
You know it's real.
If you meet it,
then what do you have to,
that's why I'm willing to,
big foot's going to say to you,
well,
it's going to say,
why didn't you fly?
Look at me.
I'm covered in fleas.
I live out here and shit.
Land.
You could have flown around for 30 days
in assignment and talk to some hairy
failed monkey hiding from its Tinier,
smaller,
far smarter.
Brethren,
pick flying pig flying
mad.
They're like,
dude,
don't even have a phone.
Okay,
there's no fucking stores out here.
I killed elk with my face.
I've been drinking my own piss
for the last thousand years.
They never have to worry
about running out of water,
but they've never found a
water collection device.
So that would mean that they
would have to live near streams.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
there's a lot.
Look,
there's clearly a lot of
problems with it here.
Well,
they're really big
too,
but then here's,
here's,
here's some on the pro side.
Here's one of the things
that they always say.
Why are we found a big foot body?
Okay,
well,
here's one thing that you need to think.
Consider,
when was the last time you
saw a dead mountain lion?
Okay.
There are a lot of God
damn mountain lions.
I mean like a thousand of them in
probably southern California alone.
She's like,
they're all over the place.
There's a lot of them.
They're not like a big foot.
It's not like a mythical creature.
It's something that we
absolutely have evidence of it,
but we never see a dead one.
But they must die.
They must.
If you believe the idea that a big
foot is something that has evolved,
it's ability to hide in a way that's
exponentially greater than any other
animal.
Then you can also add to that the idea
that they would know to bury their dead.
We bury our dead.
When was the last time
you saw a dead human?
You know,
unless you're living in Syria right now,
you've probably,
it's probably,
I mean you don't see them that often.
It's a rarity.
We bury our dead.
It's not like dead bodies are always dead.
Humans are laying around and just saying
maybe these apes or whatever they are,
they bury their dead,
which is why we don't see
their corpses anywhere.
Right.
That's a very good point and it's a very
good possibility if they really were
this intelligent thing.
And in fact,
one of the guys that we talked to,
this guy talk to,
to talk to who the fucking money,
excuse me,
one of the guys we talked,
it was a guy named William Jev Nick,
and he is a guy who had his own experience
with Sasquatch when he was 14 years
old and the guy did not seem like a cook.
He was not,
he did not register at all.
I'll say that again,
did not seem like a Kook.
He did not register it all.
My crazy scale seemed like
a very reasonable guy.
He's an author and he was telling his
experience and he was saying that when he
was 14 years old,
he,
he saw a fucking Sasquatch.
I believe he believes it.
He believes it.
Yes.
I think there are people who
believe they seen this thing.
You know,
it's for sure there's no question but
that there are people who believe that
they seen a thing,
but that doesn't mean that
they've actually seen the thing.
There's people in Alabama who think
there's a Leprechaun and the inner cities,
it doesn't mean it's there.
This dude thinks he knows
where borough ground this.
Oh,
that's why that's different.
This is where it gets
weird and this is what,
this is where I had to go.
Hmm.
Because he was making sense to me.
He was a,
uh,
a reasonable man.
He obviously was educated.
He spoke very well.
We were having a,
a nice smooth conversation.
And then he tells me that he
knows we're burial around is okay.
He tells me he knows where a burial
ground is and he says he's known it for 20
years.
So I stop and I'm going,
well,
what are you talking about?
Like if you,
you know,
where a burial ground is,
man,
like,
hold on a second.
Why didn't you go and dig it up?
All right.
Well,
you know,
the Sasquatch,
they're not gonna like it if you do that.
Let me you something.
And this is the same thing
that Tom Powell said.
Tom Powell,
who was a,
um,
a teacher in Oregon also told us
that he's had Sasquatch experiences,
also told us that he wasn't a
believer until something happened.
And then he saw it and then all of a
sudden became a believer but also told us
he knows where Barrow Grind is.
When I said,
tell me where it is,
I go,
you tell me where it is,
I'll bring in a bunch of mercenaries
and we'll dig the shit up.
Like,
let's find out what's up.
You tell me,
you know where it is.
If it's really a dangerous area,
I'll bring in a bunch of dudes with guns.
It won't be dangerous anymore.
We'll bring in people with
shovels and we'll dig it up.
Come on.
If it's still there,
we'll dig it up.
Sure.
And uh,
the fact that they haven't done
that is where I start going,
when are we really dealing with here?
Right?
When you're dedicating your life to this
thing that you have zero evidence of,
what do you,
what are we really doing here?
And when you're telling me that you saw
this thing when you were 14 years old,
I believe you.
I believe that you believe you.
It's w that's what I mean
when I say I believe you.
Sure.
But I don't know.
I when people tell me stories about
shit that I just did five years ago,
I go,
Oh yeah,
oh yeah,
I forgot about him.
I didn't even,
I forgot he was even there.
And then you start re re imaging,
right?
The past in your mind.
And I think that when you're dealing with
something as insane as seen big foot,
especially big foot when
you're 14 years old,
it gets real sketchy so that when you're
repeating the story x amount of years
later,
you're basically lying.
Right.
I'm basically lying when
I talk about my childhood.
Okay.
I know some very vague
facts about my childhood.
Yes.
But when I tell you,
I can remember this like it was yesterday,
me and Grandpa was fishing and Grandpa
was the only one that paid attention to
me and he cared.
And why I caught that fish.
He was so happy.
I don't fucking remember
what Grandpa was it.
He might've been drunk.
He might've passed out.
I'm going to made it all up.
I might have,
might have danced it all in my head.
Yeah.
I don't remember what I did five days ago.
Exactly.
The whole thing's a murky blur.
I can barely remember
what I had for breakfast.
Exactly.
So when someone tells you
about a big foot story,
it may or may not be an accurate story.
I would say it is not an accurate story.
I don't believe in big foot.
And I think that the,
uh,
that the,
that,
uh,
having played Sasquatch advocate,
I have to say,
let me give you an example.
You know,
where a big foot burial ground is,
right?
Like,
you know that,
you know,
this thing I can tell you there,
I could take you there.
You know,
uh,
you know,
where a big foot burial ground is.
This would be one of the most monumental
anthropological discoveries of,
of our generation,
of maybe,
of our time.
And you're not letting your
species know about this thing.
Why,
why?
Well,
here's the thing,
Dunkin,
um,
when you've squatting,
as long as I
have,
you basically consider the squatch
to be somewhat like family and a,
I don't consider these
things to be creatures.
I consider these things to be my
would brethren and my forest friends.
Can I ask you something?
Character Joe Rogan's playing.
Are you on a TV show right now?
Um,
occasionally I am on a TV show
looking for squatch squashing.
So you're revealing to the entire
planet the existence of big foot,
but you don't want to prove
it with a burial ground.
Well,
I don't like the snippets of your tone,
sir.
Can,
I'll tell you right now when
I'm looking for squatch,
it is 100%.
There's no bad intention involved.
I have love for the squatch.
The squatch community recognize me.
In fact,
I know their favorite food
is peanut butter and Jelly.
I leave it in the gifting tree outside
my house and it's often gone when I
return.
All right.
Well I gotta go.
What do you like?
Don't go and get the check.
No.
A man who lives on
nothing but water and air.
No,
no water shit.
I forgot.
Oh Man.
But you,
to me it seems like it's absolutely,
if they have discovered
some proof of these um,
beings existing,
I think it is unethical to not reveal
it because the ethical thing to do would
be to show the burial grounds so that we
can create nature preserves to protect
these precious woodland creatures from
logging and all the variety of things
that
you really think that the government
is going to protect the squatch.
Yes.
This was the other thing.
This guy believes,
this guy believes that the government
actually is aware of the squatch.
Yes,
and the government is hiding the squatch
because the government thinks that
society itself would fall apart
much like an alien invasion,
much like in an alien invasion scenario,
religion would fall apart.
How do you explain the giant wood
man that was not in the Bible?
How do you explain it?
10 foot tall person thing.
Who lives in the,
in the woods and can spot
camera traps a mile away.
Wait a minute.
There's a scar.
Squatch I'm going to burn
down the White House,
right?
All right.
Now here we go.
Proponent.
Here's proponent,
pull up.
There's a photo of gigantic [inaudible]
and there's a gigantic pithy guests that
is right beside.
It's standing beside a person.
It's a,
it's a recreation.
It's a man in a recreation of this
animal and this is where it gets really
weird.
Gigantic [inaudible] is an animal that
they found out about in the posit carry
shop.
There's that photo and then there's
another one that's kind of even more
interesting because they
did it in front of a jungle.
Yeah,
that one right there.
Now look at this fucking thing.
Spread this out.
Here's what's crazy.
That was real.
That's a real animal.
They have bones.
They have teeth.
They know that this thing was bipedal
base in the shape of his lower jaw.
This was an animal that existed is as a
hundred thousand years ago and existed
in Asia and they didn't find out about
this to the 1920s there was a guy who
went into an apothecary shop.
I should probably credit him here.
Let's see.
Gigantic.
Oh pick.
It kind of looks like an orangutan.
Yeah.
But except stands up on its fucking
hind legs and it's 10 feet tall.
Other than that,
yeah,
it will be.
So then if you saw an orangutan in
the zoo and right behind it was that,
you'd be like,
what the fuck is that?
It's a 10 foot tall.
Rang Tang that walks like a person.
Holy Shit.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I just liked the idea of those two
actually being friends in real life,
like a superhero team.
Okay.
This is the guy's name.
The gentleman's name is [inaudible]
Ralph.
Yvonne calling's Wald,
Cohen's Wald,
Ralph Vaughan Cohen's wall.
And he was in the apothecary
shop in China and there's a,
it was in a light Ching
Cave in light Luzio China.
I might've said that wrong.
Anyway,
he found these teeth as well as several
job bones and this apothecary shop.
And he apparently he was a,
um,
he was,
uh,
I believe he's an anthropologist.
And he went and he found these bones and
I think he recognized right away that
these were primate.
Right.
And that they were way too big to be
human and way too big to be gorilla.
He was like,
what the fuck is this?
Right.
The people in the Chinese apothecary
shop just thought they had some random
bones.
Sure.
And they actually were
calling them dragging bones.
Um,
and uh,
they trace these teeth back to their
source and it resulted in recovery,
have more teeth and a rather
complete large mandible.
Now by 1958,
it says here on Wikipedia that three
mandibles and 1300 teeth had been
discovered.
So they know that this is a,
for sure real animal and the most recent
fossils are a hundred thousand years
ago.
That's when you look at that thing
and you hear a big foot story.
That's fuck,
that's fucking big foot.
I mean that thing next
to that guy is big foot.
Right.
But again,
they didn't find a skull.
They found teeth in a job bone
and they made Chubak out of it.
They didn't find a skull.
It's true shape
of the lower jaw.
They couldn't determine that
this was a bipedal animal.
Okay.
Cause it's not determined it's hair color.
No,
that's,
that's totally made up.
That's also with Neanderthal,
you know,
within thall notice I
said all this time when,
when you,
um,
look at neanderthal imagery,
that's all made up.
In fact,
there is a,
a guy who thought of Neanderthal is a
Predator and he had this whole paper that
he wrote and,
and,
and he even had a video made of proposing
that neanderthal had black skin,
like a gorilla.
And that neanderthal where these super
muscular predators that hunted humans,
and that's why we drove
them to extinction.
And he actually bases this
on the shape of their jaw.
She's like,
we impose human characteristics
to neanderthals,
but if you look at it in the end,
are tall skull next to a homosapien skull,
they're very different.
The shape of the eyes different.
Now,
if we know the chimpanzees exist and we
know the grills exist and we know that
their facial structure is actually more
similar to a neanderthal than ours are.
Yeah,
why wouldn't we assume that
they had skin coloring and,
and,
and skin texture that was
very guerrilla like right.
And so this guy made this video,
see if you could pull
that up neander tall as a,
as a Predator
of humans,
as a Predator of humans,
free tour of humans.
I'll tell you what I find.
It's called them and us.
Okay.
So look up them,
them and us how the
neanderthals were a oppressed.
But this guy had um,
images that he created and he,
he wrote a book detailing
this theory and I'm,
his theory was that we had excepted a
vision of what Niana tall looked on,
looked at,
looked like based entirely
on what we look like,
right.
And he saying,
well,
there's no evidence of
that and you might as well,
you might as well look at it as
being far closer to a gorilla.
And he gives a bunch of reasons that
have to do with the size of the bones.
Sure.
They had much different
bone structure than us.
They were like 200 plus pounds
and they were like five feet tall.
They were totally weird looking.
There were not like a person.
Yes,
it's just in the reconstruction
that you just showed me.
If you're saying this came from teeth
and a jawbone and you're saying this was
done by the professor,
Loreal guy in the picture with
the hairy Orangutang like thing,
I want to know where did
you get the hair color from?
Why is the hair color that long?
This being it'll know.
Listen.
You know what I mean?
You're right about that for sure.
Because I think anybody could take a few
teeth in a Java on and stick that into
a Sasquatch replica and say,
look,
it's proof mom.
Yeah,
sort of.
I mean,
I guess you could,
but what we do know,
I mean that's just speculation,
but we do know this is,
this is a real animal.
So whatever this was,
whether it looked like that.
Yeah.
Or it didn't look like that.
We know it was huge.
Well,
this is absolutely gigantic,
far bigger than any primate that's
ever lived since then or before then.
As far as we know,
if you look in the book of Genesis,
there's reference to these
beings called the nephilim.
Then nephilim were these giants.
They said they were
giants during this time.
And,
um,
you know,
who knows whether that's real or not.
But I think all mythologies
have referenced to these
giant human things that
used to wander the earth.
Well,
we know,
think about human giants
that we know about.
Okay?
Think about guys like
Shaquille O'Neal or Hong Man,
Troy or real giants,
right?
They have a lot of physical problems.
And then think about what
it takes to create a fossil.
It's incredibly difficult
to create a fossil.
The only way you create a fossils,
if you get caught in a landslide or a
volcano or something happens where it
preserves your body,
you can get in mud.
But most of us are not
going to be fossils.
Most of us are just going to rot.
We're going to go into the ground
and then worms are going to eat us,
and then we're going to cease to exist.
So we're going to be transmuted
into the next age of the afternoon.
I haven't praise,
praise,
praise Shiva.
But what we,
what we do know is that
there's been people our size
and then there's been these
little tiny hobbit people.
Yes.
I think it would be ridiculous
to think that it's not possible.
They could have been giant piece.
Sure.
There was giant lizards,
giant birds.
There's been giant elephants.
Giant Tiger's.
If you go down to the labrea tar pits,
just check out the sculptures
of the dire wolves out there.
Those things used to
wander around Los Angeles.
How big were they?
Huge.
Like horse size wolf.
What?
Direwolves Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Now they're not going to be horse size.
I'm gonna say probably huge.
Well,
did you?
Yeah.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
did you ever Dire Wolf Los Angeles?
She's going to bring up a crappy band.
Remains of nearly 2000
dire wolf's were Exuma.
They lived 9,000 years ago.
Okay.
How big were they or not?
It doesn't say
there were huge.
All I believe you bro.
Look at,
I mean,
look at,
look at a saber tooth
tigers for God's sake.
Look at those things.
Those things used to wander around La.
Well,
not only that,
that was only like 10,000 years ago.
Yeah.
So the idea that there were giant
humans are giant primates is not,
to me a particularly shocking notion.
I believe that it's just hard for me to
imagine that one of them has managed to
somehow exist in the present day.
It's also disturbed
bang.
And this is one of the
things that we resist.
We resist danger that we're not aware of.
When you're resistant,
like call,
come on.
I was talking to someone about a,
um,
this is a community that's experiencing,
they,
uh,
they live near a factory and they're
experiencing like all these issues.
And I was talking to someone who,
uh,
it was saying like,
hey man,
like this,
this community might be
poisoned because of his factory.
And then I talked to another guy,
I was like,
oh listen,
that's nonsense.
Let me tell you something that if that
was true and he starts rattling off some
reasons why he doesn't believe it's true.
And then I asked him if he had
looked into it and he hadn't.
And then I realized,
okay,
we're dealing with like reactions that
humans have when we want to categorize
dangers and we want to put them in it
clearly definable categories and we have
to wonder whether we
want to worry about them.
And some things you worry
about never take place.
And if that's happens,
then you're a little worry wart and
you're a pussy and then you're ruining
society,
right?
Because you're a big wimp and
people don't want to be a big wimp.
So when people don't
want to be a big Wimp,
they dismiss things that may or may not
be real and may or may not be a danger.
And they do it as a defense mechanism.
And so it's not entirely
objective the reaction to any,
any thing.
Well,
when you bring up big
foot people immediately,
ah,
shy,
you're gonna love for big
foot guide and look for the,
Oh,
what else are you going to look for?
Leprechauns well,
let me know when you find a Pegasus
out there,
fella,
and take a ride around the
world in the flying in horse,
it's probably real.
I mean the Greeks made a statue of it.
Why would they,
why,
right?
Why would they lie?
And what he's doing by berating you and
by dismissing this topic is not just
dismissing something that is
preposterous and is ludicrous and stupid,
but he's also making himself feel better
because he's scared because he's a
scared little bitch.
Worried about that guy started big foot
and his giant Rasputin Dwarfing Dick,
big foot must have a dick like a giraffe.
It was probably like a
giraffe neck tied to his cock.
It's just is gigantic
and it's probably black,
like coal.
I'm scared of so many things.
I'm scared of taking my
shirt off at a swimming pool,
but I am not scared of bigfoot.
And my reason for not believing in
bigfoot is not because I'm afraid that my
belief in bigfoot,
some big foot's gonna come trouncing
into my house in Silverlake.
I'm,
I don't believe in,
first of all,
you fucked up and telling
people where you live.
Second of all,
hunt me down.
And second of all,
you say all this shit because you
haven't seen Bobcat Goldthwait it's movie
Willow Creek.
I like to watch bobcat calls,
wigs,
big fuck movie,
which is sensational.
It's amazing.
You'll shit your pants,
you're gonna be afraid to get out of
the car and take a leak if it's dark out
and you're near a patch of woods.
Look,
I don't know if big foot's real and I
know you don't know if big foot's right,
but I know that we both think
it's an interesting subject.
Why is that?
Well,
because it's a beautiful idea.
It's this idea of a being that is somehow
managed to evolve to a place past the
intelligence of chimpanzees and gorillas
and yet simultaneously has reached this
harmony with nature and is living
out there and some kind of beautiful
primordial pagan state.
There's something really
wonderful about that idea.
It's like avatar depression.
Yes.
It's like a version of Avatar depression.
Like when people went to
see that movie Avatar,
when you see those noble
people who would never lie,
and although they may exhibit a little
bit of jealousy and they take that fake
Navi into their arms because they're
beautiful people and they get their
internet from a tree and
it comes down from this,
this have some sort of a wifi thing
where it's like the float and whatever,
they can hide their tails.
Yeah,
exactly.
But there's something about
that that's wonderful.
And one of the things that you and
I experienced is we went and we,
we went to mount Rainier with the lovely
and talented cast and crew and we,
we went up there and we wandered through
those woods and we went to a bunch of
different areas where people have
claimed to have seen Sasquatch before.
And the thing that's struck me,
besides the fact that it was
unbelievably beautiful up there,
I have never been to the woods of the
Pacific northwest in my adult life.
I actually talked to my dad about it and
he said we went camping up there when
we were was when I was much,
much younger.
I think I won like seven and I don't
remember it because apparently it was like
rainy and miserable and we hated it and
we got out of there like it wouldn't be
like the funnest place to go camping,
but it literally is an,
I hate the word,
literally.
Sorry.
Used it really is like you're
stepping into another dementia.
Yes.
It's beautiful and it's
so rich with plant life.
Yeah,
it's the plant life.
This is how you consider it.
Let's pretend that the,
the salt lake is a blank slate.
Okay.
Salt Lake in Utah was that flat?
The flat plains or there's the
salt flats where they race cars,
they take cars and the going a thousand
miles an hour because there's nothing
out there,
but it's flat salt.
Right.
If that's a flat plane and
that's a zero life environment.
The,
the rain forests of the Pacific
northwest is a 100% life environment.
Yes.
Every inch is taken up by plant life.
There's elk running across.
We stepped an elk shit
every other step everywhere.
It was everywhere.
We were driving down the road.
Elk would just walk right in front of us.
These giant wild cows,
which are more related to
cows in the yard to a deer.
Actually,
she huge,
enormous,
four or 500 pound animals just
walking across the street.
It's a wild place to sit.
You have an accurate account on that.
Like what are you going up
there and measuring shit.
Who's going up there?
You know?
Even though it's right next to Seattle,
even though it's 50 plus
miles outside of Seattle,
no one's going into those words.
No one.
And when you're there
and you take that in,
that's when you really
start considering it.
You really started going with eight maybe.
Sure.
You know when I went out there,
I didn't realize how
dense it was out there.
I,
I had never considered that.
And when you see how dense it is
and how thick it is out there,
then you do start entertaining the idea
that there's the possibility that some
extremely endangered being could be
hiding out in these depths because people
aren't going to go into that.
What purpose do people have
for going into that stuff?
The,
I imagine that there's naturalists and
maybe hardcore hikers who are crossing
maybe point 10th of a
percent of that terrain,
if that,
yeah,
so in that way you could see how there
could be a being existing out there that
maybe hadn't been discovered yet
and when we sent the drones up into the
sky to like overlook the area and when
you put the goggles on and you could
see through the drones and you're flying
over the,
it's majestic.
Yeah.
I mean it is majestic.
It is unlike any place that I
have ever been to in my life.
I was humbled by the life.
Yeah.
Humbled by the plant life.
There's something about the amount of
trees that you see up there in the density
of it.
All that is just like,
it puts you right in your place.
It just goes sit down
and look at this and you,
you,
it's almost like psychedelic,
like you walk into those forests,
it's almost the whole world
changes and when you're in there,
you might as well be in another dementia.
Sure.
It's so not the human world and you
walk in and every hour or so you'll find
some shit on the ground
that a person left behind,
but you're on.
Once you're cutting one path,
how much are you dealing with
around you that you never see?
If you lived up there in the
Pacific northwest for the
rest of your natural life
and just every day you just crossed a,
a certain area off your list and just
walked up and down and up and down and you
made a grid,
you're,
you're going to die
before you ever see true.
Even a tiny fraction of the
woods that are around you.
And even with all the
logging going on up there,
it's not happening in every
single part of that area.
So
not only that,
I mean you'd want to make the argument
for us and intelligent animal being able
to avoid you.
How much easier is it to know you're
there then when you're chopping fucking
trees down with a saw that go,
right,
I'm listening for elk SnapID twigs.
Okay.
And I hear a fucking saw and I
smelled that stinky fuel burning.
Yeah.
Uh,
if,
uh,
if a gorilla for whatever reason,
got pushed out of a van
in the middle of Brooklyn,
it would stick out in
the most profound way.
It would within four seconds around the
entire world will be videos of a gorilla
in Brooklyn.
And the same way a human wandering through
the Pacific northwest with our stinky
perfumes and deodorants on smelling of
the cheese burger you just ate before.
You're weird,
impotent little hike,
you know,
two miles into the wilderness,
that would be so easy to avoid.
Creatures can already avoid us.
Anyway.
Cotton root beer farts.
Yeah,
we're in doctor Scholls.
Bud Light in your backpack.
Old Spice on your stupid armpits.
Yeah.
This think of your tumor is
coming out of your mouth.
They smell that stupid fluoride
toothpaste you wash your face with.
So it'd be so we would,
we stick out like a sore thumb in that,
in that terrain,
even though our ancestors,
that's what we used to live in.
We were born into that.
It used to be where we were
born into that wilderness.
And there's something that happens when
you go out there under that wildness
where some mild little
shift happens to you.
You know,
there is something that happens in another
part of your mind begins to activate
when you're out there.
And I think that part of your mind that
activates is the part of the mind that
Sasquatch hunters use
when they hallucinate.
They're imaginary.
They see,
well,
unfortunately that might be
actually what's happening.
That's what's,
what's,
um,
that's what's the most messy part of
this situation is that you can't pick a
horse.
You don't want to be the
guy that says no Sasquatch.
You guys are silly
because that guy's a dick.
Sure.
Okay.
And you don't want to be the guy that goes
all Sasquatch,
bigfoot research centers of America
and gets it tattooed on your ass either
because that guy's a dick as well.
I don't want to be a guy squatting.
What does squatch what is,
what'd you say?
Squatch was again when we were out there.
Watch is then a name for the uh,
dried semen that accrues and the
hair and the beard hair truckers.
You've been hanging out at truck
stop glory holes called squad.
Oh,
I shit.
And then you got some squats
and your beer brother.
He's the reason why the hardcore homos
at truck stops only on mustaches.
Right?
Because we all know
the hardcore gay dudes.
There's like three types of
people that have mustaches.
Mexicans,
John Stossel and hardcore
gay dude inhaler.
The kind of hardcore gay dudes that were
like leather biker hats and like cutoff
Jean shorts with Timberland's.
Yeah.
Hardcore,
hardcore,
thick pasty.
They're trying to avoid squash and they
don't want to deal with Washington squat
beard.
It's annoying clumps up and
it smells like dried bleach,
burnt rubber.
When you wash it out.
Greg Fitzsimmons goes on stage in San
Francisco where we're doing San Francisco
together.
He goes on stage and he goes,
you know what I love about San Francisco?
He's still have real faggots.
I think it was real guys with like Jean
leather vest on but and cutoff Jean
shorts and that's hilarious.
Like the Blue Oyster
bar and police academy,
there was a lot of gay
people in the crowd too.
And they,
they loved it.
They were cheering,
you know,
and that,
that kind of stuff drives me crazy
because on paper or if you put that on the
Internet,
people can get mad at him.
He could.
But,
but Greg Fitzsimmons is like one of the
least homophobic guys you will ever meet
in your life.
Like he has a great story about wanting
to find out whether or not he was in the
gay sex when he was young.
So he like got drunk and got up his
courage and then like found a guy and his
gay area that he knew and went to the
woods with them and then fucking panicked
and ran away.
He's like,
I know,
but like he's not even
remotely homophobic.
Like he's not afraid
of telling that story.
He's not homophobic at all.
So when he goes up there and says,
I love San Francisco is
still has a lot of faggots.
Yeah.
And like they,
they like were clapping.
I saw a gay couple that
were like going there,
cause he was saying it was,
it was in,
within coming from anger or fear.
It's coming from an accurate
assessment of San Francisco.
And that's fine.
It's not a,
it's not a black or white issue.
Not to Hertz.
There's,
there's,
uh,
there's a lot of shit going on when you
say that word because a lot of shit,
you can say it in a beautiful way.
And the way he was saying
it was describing a wild
looseness and an acceptance
of homosexuality in San Francisco that
allows men to be really flamboyant.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
Sure.
That's a good thing.
So what he was saying was a good thing,
but that's what's pissing me off about
this current state of like criticizing
standup comedy is if it's a statement,
these are not statements.
We're saying we're saying wacky shit,
we're just talking.
What makes the thing offensive
is the energy behind it.
When you hear a fundamentalist
right wing Christian,
say homosexual,
it's the same way as when you hear a Nazi,
say the word Jew,
it comes out in this like sizzling.
It's like,
it's the sound of like,
you know,
and the alien when they kill the alien
and that acid drips through the metal,
it's that same,
just vile is dripping hate homeless.
It's like all the hate inside.
That person is coming through the
window of the word homosexual and that's
offensive.
But when Greg Fitzsimmons says Faggot,
that's like somebody throwing
glitter in front of a disco ball.
There's nothing dangerous or
angry or pissed off as sweet.
There's nothing bad about it.
And isn't it funny that when,
this is something that took a
while for humans to figure out,
but now there is a knee jerk reaction
that when someone rallies against
homosexuals is angry about homosexuals
as fighting off homosexuals.
They're most likely k
100% k most likely gay.
Just so when did people figure that out?
Was it 1980 I don't know
how it even happened.
I think that's way more recent
that people want to admit.
I think the idea like was really
crystallized with Ted Haggard.
Sure.
When that guy got busted in
his gay prostitute friend
who likes to do math with,
went on CNN and was like,
that guy's crazy.
Yeah,
I might be a gay prostitute.
That doesn't mess with my clients,
but this guy's fucked up mind guys,
this guy's out there
fucking making mistakes.
The weight,
the weight Christians come out of the
closet is they say they hate gay people.
That's how you know you're gay.
If you ever ever hear a Christian talk
about how bad it is to be a homosexual,
it's 100% you're like,
you poor bastard.
Just do it.
True,
true.
Yeah.
And who cares?
It's like the what?
What's good about being gay is you get
to find out who's an idiot around you.
If you came out and you were gay
and some people got upset at you,
great.
You found the idiots in your neighborhood.
Yeah.
Unfortunately for a lot of people,
if their fucking parents,
I mean when you,
when you look at when they post letters
on reddit where like people come out of
the closet and their parents write
letters saying you have to leave the house
and will never talk to you again.
It's like,
oh,
they got off light man.
If they had good friends,
they got off light.
I swear to God.
If my parents would
like that and I was gay,
I swear to got to be happy.
Now tonight,
right?
2013 at 45 you mean you escape from using
with mass holes in a certain point in
your life,
you have to realize that your family
is not just what you were born with,
Shit.
It's also what you accept,
what you bring into your world
and what you create when you,
yeah.
When you're 14 right?
Of course and
your worst.
Think about just just
think of the reverse.
I mean it's like if when
I was 15 and I knew that,
I told my parents that I loved
going down on this veiny albino and,
and
I would like to thank that.
If you are my son,
I could work through that with you.
I would like to tell you that listen,
there's no perfection to this life.
And there's the beautiful thing about
life is it everybody likes something
different.
Okay.
And then everybody is different.
Some people have blue eyes,
some people love to suck.
Cock.
No,
I'm not saying sucking cock.
I'm thinking,
imagine if you as a child
knew that talking about you,
telling your parents that you like
licking pussy would get you thrown out of
your house.
Imagine the horror of that.
Like your entire sex drive.
Sure.
In a teenager you,
your sex drive is like you
have sclerosis explosive.
And to know that,
revealing that that Makin revealing
that mechanism to your parents could
actually get you banished from,
could make you homeless.
It's terrifying when you're 14 that's fun.
It's terrifying.
But you know what the real problem is?
Human beings have isolated
themselves into these much,
much more small and more
segregated communities.
And we call them families,
right?
And we know we're not in a community
anymore that has a hundred people in it.
We're all going hunting together and,
and,
and sharing festivities were on the fire.
Now we're in these communities where we
have tribes of like a very small group
at four or five people.
That's right.
You know,
my tribe is a,
I have three daughters in May.
That's my tribe,
you know,
and I have friends who I allow into my
camp occasionally and we break bread and
then they go back to
their tents and that's it.
Yeah.
And that's the reality of modern man.
The old days,
people,
tribes up together and they got,
you know,
50,
60 people and they got together and
they all knew everybody and they,
they,
they existed in these communities where
they all shared hunting duties and
cleaning duties and parental duties.
And that was how people
lived a long time ago.
What were we really fucked up
as we removed accountability,
when we stopped being communal,
we stopped being communal
in our child rearing.
We stopped being communal in our,
our our relationships.
Sure.
And that's where like bitch behavior
comes from to when you got a guy who like
starts texting your wife or
your girlfriend or you know
a girl you're dating and
says like stupid shit about you.
Like that's supposed to all be done.
Like out in the open.
Yeah.
When a guy starts sneaking around on
Facebook and saying mean shit about you to
somewhere,
what is he doing?
He's revealing his wheat genetics.
He's a loser.
The guy's a bitch and the
girl will never respect him.
What he's doing,
he,
she's,
she knows what he's doing.
She knows he's being like,
we can see creepy and Shitty,
but they think we'll just
turn to tell you that goes,
doesn't appreciate you.
I know he does where he is with you.
I see that you're hurting on the inside
and then just want to look totally
platonic.
I am your friend.
I mean,
I don't,
you're very beautiful and I would
be honored if you ever be with me,
but I know you're known to be so friends.
This guy's an asshole.
Why does that Guy Exist?
Because you can't go hunting with them.
And woopsie got hit by our streets beer
book now that he's supposed to take that
guy with you on,
on the,
the manly duties and throw him in a lake,
some white sand pits made
for that type of human.
That type of behavior is not supposed
to be fostered to the point where he's,
uh,
a member of society,
a trusted member of society.
But oftentimes in communities,
people deal with deceptive,
like traders,
traders of their friendship traders
of there because we've separated,
we've removed accountability.
You can shut your door and lock it and
just send the country email and everybody
has removed themselves
from this process of,
of community.
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
it's amazing how are,
how,
how bad that is for our
continued evolution.
The fact that people like that,
um,
have any kind of impact
at all is pretty horrific.
And that's where Avatar
depression comes in
cause it shit doesn't exist in Avatar
and it doesn't exist in the squash
community either.
Right.
I don't think there's any bitch squashes.
I think squash is in my mind.
Okay.
Whether or not the real in
my world squashes are noble,
they're very smart.
They run after elk and they check them.
They probably choke them.
They'd probably get a
good strong rear naked.
Yeah,
I'd probably just break their necks.
Uh,
uh,
Alex probably made out of
Styrofoam compared to a squat
when we went squashing
one of those guys said,
I liked what you said
that because it is true.
When we went squatting,
when we thought we went through,
a few people can say that we went
squashing and I remember one of the,
I clearly remember one of our fellows
squashers our teachers squatters.
They said that the way the Sasquatch
hunts is it breaks the leg of the elk and
then after snapping it's leg,
that's when it kills it.
I don't know why it doesn't
kill it all at once,
but it grabs,
it breaks its leg and then lets it kind
of pull itself through the wilderness
and then eats it.
That's the way the noble Sasquatch hunts.
It also can turn into a bird and it
also can sound like a leaf blower.
I can also tell you that that gentleman,
the same gentleman that told you that
story also told me that one time he was in
front of a blackberry
Bush and he heard a frog.
It was like,
read it,
and he said,
now why would a frog behind
in a blackberry Bush?
And he goes,
you know what I thought about?
I was like,
that's probably a big foot.
Yeah,
sure.
So just say no.
Same Guy.
I came,
God,
there's some critical thinking right
there that it should be in the CIA.
I see.
Hear a frog.
It's near a blackberry.
Bush must be an undiscovered
primate of enormous proportions.
Fucking shit.
It could be.
Maybe it's a crazy frog.
Maybe it's a frog.
That eight,
a psychedelic mushroom doesn't
know what the fuck is going on.
He's hiding in bushes.
He can't even eat berries.
He's lying on his back.
He's,
he's,
he's flying on a rainbow glitter all
the way to Jupiter that he's a frog and
he's understanding space travel for the
first time and he knows that he's got a
couple minutes to go before the silicide
and leaves the system and then it
becomes a frog again.
Just what's around flies.
Can I make one point
real quick about this?
I think squashing is the hiking
what renaissance fairs are to parks.
It's,
it's I,
how do I say that better?
No,
no,
no.
I just watch watching
in history to history.
I think squashing is to hiking what
renaissance fairs are to history.
I think it's a way to turn hiking
into this exciting play time,
play time.
That's what it is.
I think that's what it is
as that you totally right.
I think you're totally right.
And I met with a guy named Scott
Nelson and he's a crypto linguist.
In fact,
he worked for the US Navy for almost
20 years to ciphering languages and he
played me some authentic,
I'm doing air quotes.
Okay.
Authentic,
big foot language and I want to
play it for you because it's,
it's pretty fascinating stuff.
He played me,
this is what's disturbing though.
He played me two very
different recordings.
One of them sounded like total
dog shit and I listened to it.
I was like,
does not a big foot.
That's a guy and he goes,
no person could make that sound.
I was like,
oh good.
We'll go.
We'll go there.
I made the sound like
I made the same sound.
It really did sound but he played
me another one that was called,
they call it Samurai chatter.
Okay.
That is really weird.
Cool and I would love it if
once this show comes on the air,
I know a lot of you are going to be like,
this is fucking bullshit.
I can explain.
I am a language expert and had some
very educated points about this,
this language that he had heard online.
Now he went into this a complete skeptic.
He had no idea that there was like a
big foot community out there and no idea
that people who are
scientists took it seriously,
but his son was doing a project and it
was playing him this big foot stuff and
him being in crypto linguistics like,
well,
wait a minute,
what is that?
Hmm.
And so he plays it and listens to it
over and over again and immediately
recognizes that this is a language and
that's where it gets weird because you're
talking about a guy who is a,
a real bonafide expert in human language.
He's an expert in phonemes and different,
different aspects of,
of,
of human language and
how to distinguish them.
So he's what's called a
crypto linguists was mean.
She would take a language that's an
unknown language and decipher it.
Okay.
So he listens to this and um,
and he decides this is a real thing.
Like,
oh my God.
So he thinks that big foot's real.
I'm going to play you
what he played for me.
Cool.
Chuck this
who several years had a cabin way up
in the remotest parts of the Sierras,
northern California.
And he was there one time
with a friend and uh,
every evening they used to have
some absolutely bizarre noises.
Um,
cool.
So then they couldn't figure out what
the hell it was and I'm so they took the
tape recorder one time and
this is what the record is.
Listen to this shit.
It is very bizarre indeed.
We decided to record the sounds fucking
weird that I was in a cabinet and I
heard that,
oh Jesus,
my hair would Tommy.
Why Low Creek Bobcat Goldthwait sticks.
People look into it.
They are very encouraged.
What?
This is more of this or is it more sounds.
These sounds,
scroll a little further ahead
and give me some more of this,
right.
Listen to this.
So this is what he determined.
He listened to this and he listened to
the sounds and it was his expert opinion
that these are not sounds that
are created by a human bot.
Yeah.
The,
this,
the tone that this speed
of the pitch though,
the way that the language
is being like exhibited,
he believed that this is a language
but that it's not being used by a human
being.
It sounds chimp,
like it does sound like,
it definitely sounds like
a gorilla mixed in with,
I see why they call it
Samurai it sounds like.
Yeah,
Asian.
Somehow there's something underneath it.
I would love to slow it
down and hear what it is.
Well he did.
He did.
He slowed it down.
And it's interesting that you say that.
He slowed it down from me and he broke
down very specific aspects of it that he
recognized as language.
And again,
you know,
we're talking about a guy who
was a crypto linguist expert,
a language expert for the navy,
so he knows what he's
talking about and it is very,
very compelling.
I don't know where that came from though.
Right?
I mean they say that it was a bunch of
people in the Sierra Nevada's and they
recorded this.
All we're hearing is some really weird
noises that a language experts say sounds
like some sort of an animal.
Oh
no,
but you're not even close.
Oh,
there's,
there's some quality to it
that just doesn't seem human.
I might be wrong because,
look,
we've,
we've all seen people that are
impressionists that do things.
Do you go,
how are you doing that?
Right.
You know,
we've all seen that.
Yeah.
So it,
it,
it might be,
you know,
I can make a dog when your dog.
Yes.
Jesus,
that's a dog.
But it's not a doubt this don't do that.
We ever do that to your
kids when they're sleeping?
No.
How rude.
One time though,
when we were on fear factor,
there was this,
uh,
this group of people and they were
blindfolded and we led them into this,
uh,
this room,
or they didn't know what the stunt was,
so they couldn't see it
because it was a big wheel.
And you know,
they would have saw it
immediately and said,
what's the wheel for?
So they,
him in blindfolded.
So as they bring it in,
blindfold them and go,
they would shit their pants dirty fucks.
So I don't know what a person can
and can't make with the noise,
cause I have to make some weird noises
with my boss and the guy from police
academy.
I perfect Winslow.
Perfect.
Colin's low could easily
do something like that.
Yeah.
So you can't just say because
you're hearing some strange,
guttural orc like language that
it's definitely a big foot.
That's something that could
easily be fake Dunkin.
There's only one way
to solve this problem.
Okay,
well you go to the
woods with me and go and
no,
come on
now.
So why would I deny
it's a dream come true.
I love to go.
Squatch all right,
let's go.
Squatch let's do it.
Let's do this.